[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos i am so
thrilled that the one of the funniest
people in the world and certainly one of
the best stand-ups in the world who
happens to be
in their 20s which is insane taylor
tomlinson
is back this is her second appearance on
the show i'm so glad she came back very
different from the first one it was
really really interesting to see how
she's grown and and evolved and i'm
really excited for you guys to hear it a
couple things to plug up top uh i do a
monthly stand-up show i'm sure taylor is
going to be on it
very soon maybe i don't know i'll have
to ask her to do this one august 5th is
the next uh
living at largo go to largo dash la.com
for tickets to that it is is that is
that what is what yeah july august
that's right august uh sorry a little
real moment a little real moment
uh but if if you're listening to this
later watching this late we do it every
month so just go to largola.com
we do it once a month come to any show
uh we've had um
mullany did it recently
uh amy schumer it's been incredible and
it's always always fun bill bird did the
last one come check it out go to
com largodeshla.com also gonna be at
montreal just for last this year we're
also doing it live you made it weird for
all our canadian weirdos go to i believe
it's hahaha.com for that and i'm going
to be at just for laughs escapes which
is the just for laughs festival in
cancun mexico so check that out if you
are going to be or want to take a trip
to cancun to be with me craig robinson
dane cook some really wonderful shows
and some live podcasts there as well
hope to see some vacationing weirdos or
just people that live in mexico that'd
be incredible um this podcast is brought
to us by our friends at ned ned is the
are the makers of some of the best cbd
and cbg
products as well as magnesium and sleep
aids that i swear by and are part of my
daily ritual not just my routine
routines are boring and mundane but
rituals these are moments to check in
with my body
slow my breath do an affirmation and
focus on the person i want to be and ned
is a huge part of that i take their
de-stress blend often at the beginning
of the day because that's when i'm
feeling stressed about all the things i
have to do helps me ease into what i'm
about to take on get into that flow
state and i also it's multifunctional
take it at the end of the day as a nice
way to calm down it's one of the most
important parts i really notice
when i don't take it because the feeling
and the effect is definitely palpable it
has the power to shape your entire day
when i take it i feel amazing and
productive and i really notice that it
helps me get into that flow state at
night i take two ned products i'm really
we're like a ned family they're mellow
magnesium 75 of american adults are
deficient in magnesium which is a
mineral essential to hundreds of
functions in the body and it really
helps me rest and their sleep blend
which is filled with cbn and botanicals
that promote deep and healthy sleep in a
science-based
baked science-backed and nature-based
way so much better than a chemical or a
pharmaceutical to get me into that deep
sleep and wake up feeling refreshed ned
cbd is cold extracted from the world's
purest usda certified organic hemp in
the foothills of the rocky mountains so
whatever your need less stress better
sleep less inflammation less pain ned
has a science back nature
based product for you and you can show
your support of this podcast so become
the best version of yourself and get 15
off ned products with code weird go to
helloned.com
weird or enter code weird at checkout
that's h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d
dot com slash weird to get 15 off and
thank you ned for sponsoring our show
and offering our listeners a natural
remedy for some of life's most common
health issues
we're also brought to us by this little
son of a
what is this
magic mind for those of you watching and
i'm holding it up this little i always
think of the witcher he has those little
elixirs that he drinks that turns him
into a superhero this is basically the
little elixir that i drink that turns me
into a superhero this is not an energy
drink this is the world's first
productivity drink it has matcha it has
adaptogens i take it in the morning with
my caffeine so if i'm having a cup of
coffee or cup of tea i take it with this
and the adaptogens in this ease it out
round out the edges of that sharp
caffeine attack and makes it a more
steady uh and productive feel it's a mix
of 12 functional ingredients matcha
nootropics which of course help us help
our brain function
and adaptogens that help you fight off
stress it
was created to be taken daily for a
sharper mind steady energy immune
support and less stress i can swear by
this you get 30 percent more done on
average five to seven hours of 30
percent more productivity after drinking
you just get in a dialed in
flow state you are not
wired uh you're dialed in uh athletes
have gatorade now we have creator aid
that's my favorite part of the ad it's
my best friend try it 15 to 30 minutes
before doing a creative project or
sitting down to work you will fall in
love i promise it fights off
procrastination brain frog fatigue and
some add symptoms and gets you into a
flow state and with a money-back
guarantee any first purchase will be
refunded no questions asked if it
doesn't meet your expectations and we
have a wonderful offer a special offer
for weirdos from the guys at magic mind
all you have to do is go to www dot
magic mind dot co slash weird and use
discount code at checkout weird for a
limited 20 off your first offer no
guys i
swear swear swear by magic mind it is
the wonderful secret weapon i use when
i'm writing when i'm podcasting when i'm
doing stand up or when i just need to
pick me up and a way to focus and dial
in i'm not just saying that i tried it
first and then we reached out and made a
partnership so i absolutely swear by it
go to
magicmind.comweird and use discount code
weird checkout for 20 off your first
order thank you to magic mind all right
everybody enjoy my chat with taylor
tomlinson i sure did i hope you do as
well get
into it yeah me too and as a sophie's
are you sobee noodles
no you're not sober
oh i was like i thought that was a drink
do you like soapy noodles i was like i
don't
i don't know what that is
no i am no i'm sober i'm sober noodles
are you soapy noodles oh i've never been
drunk
did we not talk about this the last time
but so much has happened so much i know
you're like it's that was pre-covered
maybe you lost it paper with the all the
writing on it you're gonna laugh at what
i wrote down i took notes during your
special you did but one of the they're
all like some of them are super fun like
i would one of these questions
i'm like this is something i would love
someone to ask me
about you'll see i'll tell you when i
get to it i but you're sobey sobeys yes
uh we started right is that okay that's
totally fine i just wanna make sure i
just didn't wanna i mean i know you were
you were demonstrably like me like
remembered a person yeah i don't want to
be wrong about who owns liquid death
that was just something i heard well god
owns um but i mean god owns all of us
god owns death
that was oh my god as a former as a
former creation
perhaps i mean i must quote this
constantly i think it's it's in jeremiah
it's definitely open on my phone but
there's a verse in the ot your joke
about the ot made me super jelly
mine is like you ever i go you ever
crack the prequel
there's some up in the old
testament
and then i go sometimes you read it and
you go jesus well not yet
and uh yours is even better everybody's
gonna have to watch um look at you look
at you i almost said look at netflix
it's so good thank you so much this is
truly the best and i'm so honored that
you're here and thank you for coming oh
my god we had such a funny interaction
at the improv where
at the end i was like i was kind of
being a little more fan girly and you
were like would you do the podcast again
and i was like absolutely i do the
podcast again you're like well i don't
want to bother you and i was like what
are we doing here what is this well that
was true communique to me yes like i i
only want to like air vulnerabilities no
that's not we don't have to have like a
heavy conversation now i just mean like
when i run into people i'm i'm sending
out those feelers of going like do you
overthink stuff too cause you remember i
was like hey i saw you at that
restaurant i ran into at a restaurant
and i didn't want to bother you then
and i did it
well you were right there you were right
by the entrance so i kind of felt like
we couldn't have not that i would have i
would have no matter what i was going to
say hi
and i felt like oh my god he feels
obligated to say hi like i felt like you
and val walked up and we're like
a comedian's here and i'm gonna have to
make an appearance i'm gonna have to
stop by like the manager of this
establishment you think you're jeff ross
just a jeffrey i tried to think who
could handle a burn jeff
i really i was like i really felt bad
when i saw you coming i was like man i
hope he doesn't feel like
obligated well i love this because to me
i've just been watching
you know so many great things happening
for you but honestly you how many years
ago did you do the podcast the first
time um it was i mean it's gotta be five
six four four i'm gonna guess four yeah
it's been a while yeah but even then i
was very
you know you know so it's not just
because you've had like these little
little but these big benchmark moments
but i'm like taylor doesn't want to talk
to me i'm like the weird that's so funny
i'm the weird guy that's so funny okay
what are you what are you guys ordering
and then so when i saw you at the improv
and told you that
correct me if i'm wrong but i feel like
women tend to talk that way more like
there's like let's
name it yes you know what i mean i want
to name it and i was like i saw you and
i felt weird and you're like i saw you
and i felt weird and then we're like we
can trust each other now absolutely you
know what i mean yes because bert
chrysler chrysler was there as well and
he was kind of being
you know he was a man yeah oh yeah burns
like sharing our fears
with you though
yeah
but i feel even safer with you for some
reason well maybe because bert is
superhuman and he sleeps for two hours
and then promotes for four hours and
films a tv show
oh my gosh he truly is like it is
incredible we did those those baseball
stadium tour dates with him and like
he's i i don't know how he does it he
like does like three hours of sleep and
then like crossfit
and then like
shoots a bunch of videos and does a
podcast and then does a whole show
and meets all these fans and you're just
like wow no one and i have the same team
as him i have the same managers and
agents and they were like so inspired by
what he was doing and they're like maybe
you could and i'm like i can't don't
don't waste your time i'm not this
nobody
is this yeah nobody can do this yes he
is truly
a in the machine like you yeah this is
not normal
like
please don't
compare me to him i'm not just kissing
his ass it doesn't seem unhealthy like
he seems like a grounded no i think he's
super human i think he truly like he's
just one of those people that like
another species yeah he's he just i eat
nails right yeah
just
i i got i i don't i don't know how he
does it i really don't know how he did
you know i don't either because if i
have two things in a day exhausted i in
fact spreading it dreading it yeah i'll
do too yeah and i'll cancel three yes
and one of them is go to lunch with val
you know what i mean like that's also a
thing yes it's not like ah a break i i
lunch with val's my favorite thing i'm
still saying it was a thing i had i did
yeah had to do meaning i had to drive
there yes you have to find parking you
have to talk to someone yes who isn't
val
lots of people who weren't found that
day so many people there you are
yeah i sometimes say that to the
audience i'm like how did you guys do it
and i actually think a lot of people
don't relate to that that when i when i
go like i can't believe we're all here
it's crazy it's hollywood some people
are just walking around going like wow
like it's virtual reality or something
they're not affected i can't handle more
than two things in a day yeah la
specifically or you're like amazed
anybody went to an event of any kind uh
for sure la specifically yeah again i
bet i have is is you ever drive by those
things on sunset boulevard a parking lot
and there's guys in orange reflective
vests with coned uh flashlights they're
going hey
they're just like circling trying to get
you to turn in yeah i'm always tempted
to turn in
even though i'm miles from where i'm
going
i'm so sensitive
to all things that that that super
freaks me out but uh yeah you're not a
bird and uh that's okay no one is
there's only one there's only one i
people
who
are that successful
in a way that like like he's like
creating like a brand like he's like
he's an experience like his fans are his
fans
and
i just
i i i
could never i could never be that i
don't if you were i wouldn't trust what
you like we were just watching your
special this morning
re-watching
loving and if you were out there just
like
thoughtlessly meaning like fearlessly i
guess we could say yes
churning out like you're filming us now
right you know what i mean or whatever
it is
i i don't think that would mesh with
what you're doing on stage because i
think you're the same thing like there
are
tay heads i don't know
sure let's go with that is that it i
don't know what are they they're just
people who like comedy they're just nice
like but they want to hear comedy about
therapy they want to hear comedy about
self-doubt
that's a difference like a rock star
like i'm not like a rocks i'm never
going to be like a rock star comedian
yeah he's a mentos and diet coke yeah
you're just a diet coke i'm bear i'm i'm
a lacroix let's be honest
and not a not a strong one
you're a pure lacroix yeah i'm
you're a
blue lacroix
the blue
i was at a kid's birthday party
yesterday and i'm this is how you know
comedians are there we're our own thing
and i'm only safe with you guys and i'm
drinking a pure lacroix and i go thanks
to whoever brought the pure lacroix
and my friend ben goes that was me i was
just like okay okay and then i and then
i went on about it actually was better
than i remember
it wasn't it wasn't that bad
this is what i wanted to open with i did
i did a spot last night
i really want to hear your your feelings
on this okay i did a spot last night
and it was awesome it was super fun
uh and then i went to a party and when
we were leaving the party i said to val
i was like
going to a party
after you've done stand-up
is like what are we doing here because
you've just done the most condensed
like i said i'll just say what i said
i've never done cocaine but i'm like
you've done a line
of social interaction being with people
having your thoughts heard and really
hearing theirs as well i mean i'm
adapting and responding to their their
responses and all that stuff and then
you go to a party and you're just
talking to one guy yeah you know what i
mean and there's a real like it's like
going from the freeway to a surface
street it's just like a real slow it's
like going to a parking lot it's like
going to a yeah yeah it's going from the
german surface street i don't
know who you're talking to but you're
giving them too much credit
i'd love to meet a surface street most
of these are parking lots
most of these guys are
cul-de-sacs
dead ends
you know what you do at a party have you
ever noticed you just move slowly
like if you're if you're three people
and you're talking wait 15 minutes
you're just kind of over here yeah and
no one no one remembers giving the order
it's because that's how uncomfortable it
is we drifted you drifted because
there's all those moments
it's not like stand-up stand-up is
perfect stories go somewhere anecdotes
have a reason there's effort there's
laughter everyone knows their roles
you're the laughers i'm the talker yeah
here we're like everyone's taking turns
and that's why there's this you shift
because it's awkward yeah step to the
left yeah every 30 seconds a tiny step
to the left yeah and you drift here's
what i want do you i just wanted to know
like stand up it's such a strange thing
to me it has this great anti-anxiety
thing it makes me feel connected makes
me feel alive i know that's maybe the
best case scenario yeah unless it goes
terrible and then it can be the opposite
i was wondering if you still feel that
way like stand up v party oh i mean i
when you said i did a set and it was
great and then i went to a party i was
like i'm out i'm out on this yeah i
can't even
i no thank you right it's one or the
other for me uh and i will dread the
party for three weeks beforehand
i
i think
you know what's funny is that show that
we did together was a sunday night it
was like amazing it was like you and
like dana carvey and david spade and me
for some reason and i had to follow you
and you just like murdered like we were
all in the back and i'm just like all
right guys i'm like
like i'm i'm about to bomb pretty hard
so just remember remember me as i was i
guess
and
it was like so crazy and the night
before
i had done both the early show and the
late show at the improv and then the
store in between
and
early show at the improv was great
show at the store was great and then i
came back to the improv for the 9 30 10
p.m show
and it was
hands down the worst audience i've maybe
ever had and i'm pretty like look i
don't have the highest self-esteem if
people don't like me i'm like all right
that's i could see that i feel that i'm
not what you wanted and that's okay it's
one of the greatest gifts you can give
by the way because there are inevitably
some people that are enjoying you and
when you're just like it's okay but this
night this night was
just objectively bad like i watched them
be
like so silent for the cold opener which
i was like okay i guess it's the cold
open so maybe they just need a minute
but like
even if you don't
necessarily like connect with the cold
opener like you'll usually be more
engaged they just weren't like just
nothing and then frasier was hosting and
they gave frasier almost nothing and i
was like okay well kelsey it's still
early
and we'll still we'll still like we'll
get them it'll be fine and then i went
up and
the it was just you know there's like
low energy and then there's like hostile
it felt both of those things
it felt like the low hostile low hostile
the biggest laugh of my set i think was
one of the first things i said which is
i feel like everyone here is on a date
with someone they know they're gonna
ghost and i genuinely think that's what
was going on it was like a lot of
couples it felt very disjointed like
didn't feel like a crowd at all it just
felt like a bunch of people with their
arms crossed and i i totally let it get
to me because i had done i was like i
was in this room two hours ago i know
this works yes and i was also like
jezelnik and like nikki were next and i
just kept telling them famous people are
coming
you have to get it together
during my set
because the famous people are coming
like what are you doing come on guys
paul revere i truly chelsea nick is
coming like he won't stand for this i
just it was crazy i felt like i was like
an open micro again but i like know i
can do it so like it really not only you
can do it you just did it i just did it
i just did it i just did it twice
and i did kind of like i did lose a
little bit where i think towards the end
i was like is everyone in here just
really hot and they're upset they have
to look at someone else like what is it
can you all pretend you're filming a
self tape
for an are you can kidding friend you're
auditioning for someone who likes comedy
like did everyone come here on purpose
like i was just upset and then i had to
kind of try today
like here and there it was i at the
improv last night just for fun just
because i i don't want you to feel alone
if they turn their back on me i love
being like you like it's just so
fun
because sometimes that's exactly what
they want was it what they wanted no no
that was that was what was upsetting is
i go okay well if they're not like
feeling the material then i'll just like
yell at them or whatever gently i'll
just you know reprimand them look and
then that's what they want but they
didn't even want that what what
with me is somebody asked them a
question like oh you some of the comic
before me was like that's a cool
sweatshirt do you smoke weed and the guy
just went
no and you're like i see a normal nice
person would be like ah not really like
you know soften it no no
yeah subtitles okay subtitles on it says
you yeah yeah and that was the
energy of the entire crowd and i saw
nikki like a few days after and i was
like how is that a crowd for you was
that bad and she goes oh yeah remember
she's like i kind of blocked it out but
they were bad and then i also asked when
i went back on sunday night when i was
there with you guys i was like the rest
of the show did it get better and they
were like no
no it didn't get better isn't that kind
of okay look i'm not being positive pete
i'm saying
you saying you ran into nicki and you
can bond over that right when you're on
the road and you bomb alone
you know what i mean and like before
you're even bringing an opener or
anything like that and it's just you
that sucks when you can at least win
it's just you yeah did you see that
yeah and you can watch comics that you
respect and love also do poorly right
that that i i hate to say it something i
want them to do poorly it's that i go
like okay it wasn't just me like all
late tonight yeah and i didn't stay
for the rest of the show so i didn't
know why would you and i was scared i
was glad i saw nicki because i didn't
want to i told her this i was like i
didn't want to text you and be like that
crowd sucked right and you're like i
thought they were fun and i'm like cool
i'll just go drive into the ocean
like i
talk about being sensitive i feel it
when i send a text out like that like
wow that cr crowd was nuts or bad i'll
actually kind of feel it in my stomach
until they reply yeah like i'll carry it
and then when they go i'll be like oh i
didn't realize how much i was waiting
for them to validate that but so much of
i noticed this at the party last night
subtitles on so much of communication is
me going like taylor sometimes i feel
this way is that okay yeah and you go i
also feel that way and that's okay cause
there's two of us yes what do you say
that's all like so much of what we're
doing yes oh my god i'm just walking
around going is anyone else afraid who
else is afraid raise of hands who's
afraid and t tom
i did the uh look i don't know if this
is true but it just seemed like bill
bird did my largo
uh show recently
and there were a lot of bilberry people
there
not that there's only one kind i'm a
bill per person i love billboard but
there were like there were a lot of guys
that looked very muscly that's all i'll
say right and i and i said and maybe
it's not the funniest line in the world
but i had done it two nights early at
the improv it did really well and i was
really like excited to say it again i
feel like you're going to like it not to
forecast but i was like
round of you say it apropos nothing you
just go round of applause who here would
just start crying if their dad looked at
them and said i'm so sorry oh my god you
did say that on the show that was the
first time that was the first time that
was i laughed so hard at that omg dead
so hard i can't wait to do it again yeah
and i swear there was something going on
that night bill would tell you too there
was something just sort of strange in
the room that night and uh it was a
great show but it was something's off
the spirit of joe rogan the spirit of
joe rogan was there
emblazoned on the men's room
i always think the joke because he has
the round head he just looks kind of and
he's boxy he looks like the men's room
symbol is that anything
oh the yeah okay sure i say that's true
of any any guy with a shaved head i'm
just kind of like the men's room so yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's not see it's me i
had to think of funny enough i had to
think of the men's room symbol because
that's not the one i'm going in you're
looking for the other one yeah i'm
looking for the other one where is
where's that dress that has no give it's
just completely out
so 50s you know
it's updated it's like a robot
the jetsons made basically it is i can't
believe you got that ref sweet ref
i used to do that a bit about that i was
like why do you guys get my references i
used to do that at colleges i'm like
everything i say
people your age still get i'm 43. but i
i have no fear of saying maybe you have
immature references it could be but
even the maid from the jetsons that's
like my dad would be like now we're
talking the jetsons are pretty you know
what the jetsons are okay i mean i don't
know let's call someone from gen z and
see if they know but is that the next
one gen z is the next one gen z is the
one right behind me and are we back
they're like two years behind me like
two years younger than me as gen z
and i feel the difference really oh yeah
what's the diff i just
i just so scared of them
you are yeah i'm really scared of them
they're so like they're just like very
i don't know they're so like open-minded
and like
like i just feel like they hate us i
know they hate us i'm on tick-tock they
don't like millennials they think we're
cringy cringe we think we're cringe yeah
yeah gross and yeah is it cringe or
critter i'm seeing i'm sweating yeah i'm
sweating i'm already panicking i'm
already panicking what is selena gomez
because when i watch she's a millennial
okay yeah she's a millennial when i
watch only murders that's the time when
i'm really like i really see that i
think she's great i really do but
there's the real difference between
steve martin martin short and selena
gomez because martin schwartz like
hitting his mark and he's like i have
now delivered my line and exit stage
right and steve martin's like oh still
do and it's still i'm dying and then
selena gomez is like are you hanging
there somewhere
wow
it's not even i'm just like
go ahead what's your take what's your
take what's you love that show do you
like the show i like it something's a
little off about it because it's so cute
sometimes i go like it's a little like
the second season i catch myself going
like it can be like a perfect dessert
that i almost don't want to eat and if
you're not in the mood for a perfect
dessert
maybe you should watch the old man right
i
i watched i haven't seen the second
season yet but i watched the first
season and i did watch it one a week
yeah and i feel like this is one of the
shows that i do feel like works once you
should watch once a week which is weird
i don't feel that way about almost
anything anymore yeah and because most
things i'm like i'll lose interest if
it's once a week but that i really was
like oh yes a new one and i think
the fact that they were like we have
these two legends and then we have like
the biggest
like young star in the world is she is
she's i think she's the most followed
person on instagram or she was for a
while really oh yeah see this is my
point i'm still like i'm old school in
the sense that i think show business
people are supposed to be like hello i
understand there are murders in the
building right no and then she's like i
don't know no younger people are like i
will watch selena gomez do anything yeah
she's got like a show where she cooks i
guess i haven't seen it but you're like
you'll watch her do literally anything i
don't know why like she's obviously
talented and stuff and beautiful but
like they're just maybe because we all
grew up with her too like i will follow
you
yeah
i i will watch her do anything really
and you know what i'm talking about with
the difference in efforting i really
feel like that's a young a millennial
thing potentially right it's like don't
act like you've been there i think if
you if i was on only mergers in the
building every take you would see in my
face i can't believe i'm on this show
like you would yeah yeah you know what i
do feel this way about i feel this way
about stand-up sometimes do you feel
this way about stand-up where you're
like
there's there's so much stand up now
that doesn't feel as polished that
people connect with totally and i feel i
i keep getting cold like old school in
like reviews of my stance you're martin
short you're not selena gomez it's so
strange when you're going like you know
what i thought when i was watching your
special i was like
either you gave yourself the note or
there's a lot of moments where like
you're in the pool there's another
moment where you're in a pool you're
like good thing i'm wearing my foot oh
every deck is like jumping in cold water
yes yes you're like good thing i'm
wearing my floaties i'm like either
that's a great commit that feels like a
line in another community would be like
you should say the floaties or taylor
just did the work yeah either way
you did it like the the whole hour is
tied up it's also exactly one hour have
you noticed yep i did that on purpose we
filmed like an hour 12 and i cut 12. to
make it exactly an hour because i think
if you see something
i think if you see something over and
out when i see something over an hour
whether it is an episode of a tv show or
a stand-up special i'm like that seems
pretty long oh yeah yeah i wonder if you
can make it so it just says three
questions mark three question marks like
a cool party eight p.m to question like
you don't know how long it is no that's
funny because then you i do that with i
saw a youtube video that was like it
might as well as long as you want yeah
we're not gonna tell you when it ends
you that's interesting i saw a
youtube video that was it might as well
have been like scientists figured out
trick to always be happy it might as
well have been called that and it was
only seven minutes and i was like i
could watch that
you won't dedicate 13. what about what
if it was 13 would you watch science
figures out how to be happy i wouldn't i
mean if you really figured it out why is
it taking so long
you obviously haven't figured it out
because you know what doesn't make me
happy wasting my time
yet
t tom what are we doing with this time
we're saving have you noticed yeah i
sound like see this is why i'm steve
martin i'm not selena she'd be like
we're doing things that way this is why
i love this podcast cause i mean they're
gonna leave more depressed or less
depressed i think my goal will be less
depressed okay guys cause you're gonna
love that question okay and then i
haven't broken the glass yet oh my god
but when we get there i also want to
like i'm a little i'm really feeling
like really a dddd this week i don't
even like i'm not one of those people
that likes belonging to that group but i
might and at the party last night i
really couldn't keep things together and
even on stage i was really i'm gonna try
and stay focused i really think people
would be interested to hear because
you've been touring a lot since i last
saw you
yeah do you enjoy it and how any weird
ones
i mean
i do enjoy i haven't been i haven't been
touring the last two months okay because
so the last show of the tour was may
7th i think may 6th 7th in uh los
angeles in the netflix fest
and i had been on the road like first in
clubs and then the theater tour for like
14 months straight like almost every
weekend every weekend for a while
and i was like hitting a wall with it
where i'm like i need some time off for
sure um you don't feel that way like
even in between shows on a saturday i'm
always like oh yeah i have to do this
again i feel it 40 minutes into the
first show then 40 minutes into the
first show
i'm like this is incredible and
why why ruin it
why do this again we did it
taylor i'm dead
i didn't know you felt that way oh my
god yeah okay so i agree you do read old
school and that to me just means clearly
this person put in the effort that that
sentence is up that point yeah yeah i
think that's why people but like but
when like vulture reviews you and it's
very nice and they go like you know it's
old-fashioned stand-up you're like i
thought i'm just trying to get good at
like the craft of it because i think i
don't have the self-esteem to like coast
on my personality like i feel like well
thank god i don't know i'm like i
thought if what i don't what's the ulti
like i can't sing like that's the only
other way
it could i could do something like
groundbreaking yeah is if i could sing
maybe but i can't sing like
i'm not
like it's like saying you're old school
painter because it's like she uses
colored paint it truly yeah where i'm
like you guys should watch kat cohen
like kat cohen's amazing and is doing
something different
and
but if you want stand up i'm over here
like
is how i feel about it and
i i don't know i i've learned to like
that
that comment but before it used to feel
like a little
bit of a weird
dig that i didn't know how to take
initially i only yeah i think you should
only take it as a compliment okay
because i think a lot of us
older people who write for vulture
i have a pen name i won't tell you which
one i am but like
we look at younger people and and the
style du jour seems to be like
don't don't look too
right like you're trying too hard yeah
uh because that's vulnerable or
something or stupid or cringe but you're
like nope here's a perfect hour of stand
up comedy but it doesn't feel like
you're going
like i really i'm watching you're not
doing i like seinfeld you're not doing
what seinfeld does where it's like every
word is perfect right you're not doing
that no that's old school i don't know
how to do like have you seen this in the
news like i don't know how to do that
yeah i'm talking about my feelings and
experiences yeah so to me that's old
school it's just like
observational
about things we're all we're literally
all just looking at
i know what's happening inside of you
incredibly modern i have a couple
questions here's one okay you say uh
you're talking about
val and i both struggle with overeating
uh like emotional eating like yes and it
has nothing to do with hunger you're
just doing it to get your mind off
something or fill a void or
for me it's often because i've i've
earned it right yeah i'm like it's a
treat i do stand up we'll go back in the
green room
every dessert just bring us every
dessert and like it took me so long to
be like
just take it take a breath just take a
breath maybe you'll have a
diarrhea or you're not diarrhea but
you'll feel like if you eat every
dessert maybe don't do that um but when
you're doing that you're like round of
applause if you've done this or done
this done this and you go okay about
seven of you and the rest of you are
like i eat for fuel right do you
remember this yeah and then you do the
then you do the examples and people are
laughing and you go sounds like more
than seven yeah and i'm like that's
really great here's the question are you
ready
is that
because you had said seven that night or
do you always say seven
i usually adjust it based on what it
feels like i always say a number but
sometimes it's more people where i go
like it feels like 20 of us okay but
it's always more than who cheers for
sure yeah i just love that those are
little moments those little pockets
that's what i mean is you're not just
doing
i think the insult in old school
is like you go up and you're in like a
plaid blazer and you're like all right
and there's no attention paid to the
medium or that it's being filmed or like
how you know what i mean you're just
doing your act like vaudeville that's
not what's happening i see you adapting
and changing and also
clearly communicating rather than
reciting i don't see you reciting oh
that's nice i would hope so yeah the
second show i posted a clip of it
netflix let me post it which was nice
the second show that we filmed that
night somebody's phone went off like
somebody in the crew backstage oh boy
and i was like can you guys all hear
that
like i just want to make sure that i'm
not doing like a mental health special
and then just losing my in the
middle because that would be hilarious
like so there's a whole clip of me just
going and then after i did that i just
went look we got it on the first show
you guys this can go however it doesn't
matter it's my favorite feeling in the
world i don't care yep and everybody's
like yay every special not not every but
the last one for sure i go we got it on
the first one yeah and you put the
pressure on them i might even say the
onus yeah you put the onus on them and
then the crowd tends to be better
because they want to be
they want to be
they want to be the special crowd
great technique great technique yeah
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought to us by our friends
at lollipop hands down my favorite new
beverage for real for real lollipop is a
new kind of soda it tastes just like the
sodas we grew up with but unlike other
sodas that are full of sugar corn syrup
and artificial ingredients like
aspartame lollipop is made with natural
ingredients that are actually good for
you they have delicious nostalgic
flavors like vintage cola classic root
beer which is my personal favorite this
month orange squeeze cherry vanilla
strawberry vanilla and classic grape i
absolutely love the root beer it tastes
just like the root beer i remember but i
haven't had regular soda like that in a
long time and this is a great way to get
it back into my happy life they use
functional ingredients that combine the
benefits of prebiotics plant fiber and
botanicals to support your microbiome
and benefit digestive health i know when
you hear fiber you think how can that be
it's soluble fiber which means it's just
blended into the water there's
absolutely no noticing of the fiber but
you get all that digestive benefit as
well as prebiotics which are wonderful
for your microbiome your gut is like a
second brain it's wonderful to support
it 90 of americans consume more than
usda's daily recommended added sugar
intake which is only 30 grams
sweetened beverages like soda like check
this out their vintage cola only has two
grams of sugar to compare that to
coca-cola which has 39 grams
every time this blows me away that's
nine grams more than you're supposed to
have the orange squeeze which is also
amazing from lollipop
has five grams of sugar compare that to
fanta which has 44.
so drink lollipop get delicious soda
back into your life made with natural
healthy ingredients and it tastes
absolutely wonderful it's non-gmo it's
vegan it's paleo and keto friendly with
less than eight grams net carbs per can
they're so confident you'll love their
products they offer a 100 money-back
guarantee for offers for orders excuse
me place through their website and we
worked out a special deal for weirdos
receive 20 off plus free shipping for
your order i recommend the variety pack
it's a great way to try all of the
delicious flavors go to drink ollie pop
dot com slash weird or use code weird at
checkout for this deal that's d-r-i-n-k
[Music]
dot com slash weird they can also be
found at over six thousand stores across
the country including including kroger
whole foods sprouts and
wegmans which they don't have in la but
if you have a wegmans go there because
that's a hilarious name
this episode is also brought to us by
our friends at real paper val and i have
made the swap to real we love it it's
wonderful and they have an incredible
incredible benefit to the earth i mean
trees are pretty great aren't they i
mean they provide shade they make oxygen
i don't know why we're not talking about
that they prevent erosion they suck up
carbon they provide homes for animals i
mean is there anything they can't do and
to turn something as awesome as a tree
and more accurately a forest of trees
into toilet paper just feels wrong why
are we wiping our butts with these
treasures it doesn't say that but i'm
asking these trees spent decades growing
only to get cut down and be flushed down
the toilet that's why i love real paper
r-e-e-l paper real makes a sustainable
toilet paper that uses 100
bamboo this isn't true but i'm pretty
sure 3 000 bamboo plants have grown
since i've started this ad that's not
true but it is a very it's a very fast
growing and renewable source much better
than trees the great thing about bamboo
is it is a super fast growing grass some
species of bamboo can grow up to three
feet per day and because it's grass
they're able to harvest the same stock
over and over without disrupting the
plant or the soil and on top of all of
these ecological benefits of using
bamboo reels paper packaging is plastic
free and compostable and you know it's
sort of hard to talk about what you're
putting on your butt
but it's soft it's wonderful it's all
the things you want toilet paper to be
and i love love love knowing that we are
not contributing to all of that waste
and harm to the environment after all
come on guys
you're wiping your butt do it
responsibly
real paper is available in easy hassle
hassle-free subscriptions or for
one-time purchases on their website all
orders are conveniently delivered to
your door with free shipping and 100
recyclable plastic free packaging i can
attest to that the packaging is
wonderful and if you head to
realpaper.com that's
r-e-e-l-p-a-p-e-r.com
weirdo and sign up for a subscription
using weirdo at checkout you'll
automatically get 30 off your first
order and free shipping
r-e-e-l-p-a-p-e-r dot com slash weirdo
and enter promo code weirdo to get 30
off plus free shipping that's 30 off
your first order so let's stop flushing
our forests and try reals tree free
paper real is paper for the planet
i love it
that by the way
am i the only one hearing that isn't
that also the point of stand up comedy
like we're back to how how we relate
it's like i'm afraid are you afraid yeah
and you go am i the only one hearing
that yeah i go up on stage and that's
why it's such a anti-anxiety for me is
when i talk about things that happen in
traffic or this or that or with my
parents or whatever it is and they laugh
i go okay i'm not the only one hearing
them yes so i feel like that that almost
could have been the name of that special
am i the only one
yeah absolutely right yeah totally i
think that was something i felt like
early on is i just thought i had to come
up with things that everybody felt and
then i was like you know what it
i'm just going to talk about things i
feel and then everybody goes not
everybody but a portion of them go me
too and you go
well i feel better and i'm just going to
focus on those things and i'm going to
focus on communicating it in a way that
it really resonates with the people it
already resonates with and then the
people who don't connect with it still
think it's funny and
learn something that's right about
something someone they know maybe the
entertainment can often be
that's not how i am but i had no idea
other people were that way yes i think
about that all the time especially after
i come
through to the other side of an issue i
realize oh some people were laughing not
bad at but they were laughing at me they
were laughing at a floundering
man who was like so obsessed about this
that or the other maybe they i thought
they were relating yeah some of them
were actually like oh i remember what it
was like to be 28. yup you know what i
mean yeah i do know what you mean
actually
do you have bits that you look back on
and you're like oh i was so
in myself that i didn't even know
i don't know i i ca not off the top of
my head that i can think of but people
would say things to me like that after
shows where they would give me that like
sort of
pitying like
it gets better your 30s or your 40s are
way better it's just it's just a
nightmare right now it's actually kind
of true though oh it totally is and i
did appreciate it but at the time you
feel kind of like yeah so were you just
sitting in the audience going
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i want to
circle back to 40 minutes through the
first
dude we were talking about it in the
green room last night where we were like
one show tonight this is so nice because
saturday we were like
can you believe we're doing two
especially after covington was at the
brea improv yeah yeah yeah with irene 2
and zach noe towers okay they're very
very funny and we were all just like
yeah like
towards the end of the first one you're
like
again yeah really yeah
it starts to feel this is why i
i like going on the road but the more i
do it the more i'm like
can we just do it once
at a bigger venue is that possible yeah
and not even a huge venue just like one
time
and and the thing also i don't like
doing it on saturday because then you're
just something that's happening as
opposed to like i love a thursday
yeah eight o'clock one show at the
firebird in saint louis you know what i
mean those are always great shows but
then like you will do those clubs and
i'm grateful to do those clubs but those
are those are where i tend to have those
feelings of like i just told this joke
and then my my job
becomes pretending like i'm enjoying it
you know what i mean yeah
i think right now i'm in like the
building phase so i'm trying to figure
out the new hour so i need all of these
shows and i need all of these reps at
these clubs but
when i have it figured out like when we
were on the the theater tour and we had
added shows because we were doing
smaller theaters
and you're doing two shows and two meet
and greets you're like i did four shows
and i'm exhausted and
and i'm doing the exact same hour pretty
much like i am very tired this is nice
if this would be great if it was just
the one tonight and even sets in town
like
you know
taking time off the road to be home the
last couple months
i was like oh just do sets in town and
that'll be great and i'm at the point
now where i'm like the improv stage
feels like a cruise ship to me
where i'm like are these different
people
i can't i can't tell i can't tell if i
did this already why why are you doing
it so much because i've been home so i'm
like well i have to get on stage so i'm
just gonna
keep doing that but i'm like i can't
keep that i went to san diego
uh and did mike drop comedy club has a
side room that's like 50 seats and i
went and did that
and during the week and that was really
fun and helpful i went and featured for
my friend dustin in san diego because i
was like i gotta get out of here like
doing clubs in la just doesn't at a
certain point you're like i can't do
this all the time yeah
this is gonna sound like a therapeutic
therapist question but what does it feel
like to not do stand-up all the time
i would like it to feel better than it
does
i can i can go like
i can go like five days without feeling
guilty
i think for the most part now yeah we've
worked up to that yeah but then
past that i'm like
you're gonna get bad you're gonna get
bad at that that's the voice yeah i took
i took two solid weeks off after the end
of my tour where i was like i didn't go
up for two weeks yeah um
and i just like focused on other things
instead but i was like i have to be
productive so i like so even then you
wouldn't fully take it off you were just
being productive on that just different
things where you're like okay i'm gonna
you know
meet my boyfriend like you're just
saying i'm gonna do this now
meet him this is when i have time to
meet you yeah i'm like look i have
i have eight weeks i've only seen you in
my periphery up until now
i know your laugh
just gonna find the one i guess
are you dating a boyfriend mm-hmm yeah
a human and i met him the day after my
tour ended oh wow i literally was like
okay we'll do this now
like
i have time for this that's interesting
okay let's get to boyfriend
when you're just
still
yeah no good here's i was talking to uh
my friend kelsey cook about this uh you
know kelsey yeah
uh and we were talking about being on
the road and coming home and like if
we're doing
club weekends
we can come home on
sunday or monday and then be totally
home for like three days and not do sets
because we got to go back
on thursday or whatever like we've
gotten to that point where we're like we
can be off
monday tuesday wednesday and if we're in
between club weekends but
like to really do nothing is very hard
to like
take days off to like clean your
apartment and like run errands and see
your family
that feels like time off
because i'm still working on things like
i'm still
it's hard for me to be totally present
and checked out and not anxious unless
i'm with another person that i care
about because then i'm still working on
something i'm working on my relationship
with my sister or my boyfriend or my
friends like
i need to be earning it yeah do you
think this goes back to the god doesn't
love me unless i do what he tells me
everything does
what doesn't go back to that
like for nikki and i were just talking
about that like yeah all these people
that grew up religious and myself
included have a really hard time
it's funny the people that were
i was told that god loved me
sort of have the hardest time believing
it you know what i mean because i blame
god so much as my father but no i know
because yes it wasn't he wasn't god it
was stapled to it yeah it's like the
george carlin thing it's like he loves
you but also you have to do all of these
things to keep him from kicking you into
a furnace which i'm sure i said the last
time he did this yeah so from that comes
did you know that's what
um well that's what richard rory says
that's what paul the apostle paul means
when he says the law it's the
performance principle it's the idea that
you can earn it oh so he's really like
railing again he says the law if you
read any like romans or whatever it's
always railing against the law and i
always thought that just meant like
being legalistic it actually means
thinking that you can earn
god's favor or your worthiness it's like
it's any notion that you're not just
sort of like already okay
uh isn't that weird that is super weird
kind of fun but then that bleeds into
even your social life you want to be
working see i relate because i like
doing this podcast i'm like oh i have
this day did not really do much taylor
and i we could have just had lunch yeah
but it's better to
bang out we did a thing this is also
productive yeah yeah yeah but it doesn't
you know you do tie it back to that a
little bit mm-hmm yeah yeah i think so
i think
i think just trying to be
perfect
is hard to get away from
and your definition of perfect changes
and i think
with stand-up specifically i think
kovid was
interesting
because
i realized how much of my identity was
wrapped up in
being
a comedian and so when we didn't have
that anymore i was like
okay
if i don't have this am i gonna be okay
am i still worth anything is this the
reason
people like me and are with me and if
i'm not this anymore
then
are those people gonna leave it's like
uh did you watch pam and tommy i didn't
there's just a line oh
okay we'll do the bit i never did on
stage but hugh hefner says to pam
anderson don't confuse your price with
your value
which is really good and i also the bit
was that's really good they put it in
the mouth of hugh hefner and maybe he
did say it but he also was like and look
at them big old titties you know like i
just i know you're like that seems
you know people are complicated i
understand
but they only had him being like a sage
yeah and i was like
you know
sure it can be both
we can handle the nuance of like and i
love the way you look in this shoot baby
can it be both
but i think don't confuse your so you're
saying and i felt the same thing during
kovid you sort of vanished we all sort
of vanished because people like you and
me
and i'm saying i'm still this way of
course i look for my identity in other
people's eyes val and i were talking
about that like we're shiny people yeah
but shiny people only exist in relation
to things that's shining a light on them
yeah we just reflect back what people
are shining onto us so when that light
goes away we're just a rock
yeah
and i need you to i'm go and if you get
close enough to me i'm going to be a
rock sometimes and i have to be i have
to be shining from a distance yeah let
me look at me glitzing
yeah don't get close to a rock i'm a
terrible pillow yeah that's your thing
yeah if if i can be the way i always
feel in relationships is if i can be
shiny
most of the time
then that will make up for
what a rock i am
for part of it yeah for this like you
know there will be
15 there will be 20 of the time that i
am
you know not shiny at all so just like
be super shiny
i wonder if i said this last time two
thirds of the time marilyn monroe had
that quote if you don't if you don't
like me at my worst you don't deserve me
right yes yeah but i don't feel that way
i feel like
if i'm not my best enough you
you won't give me a pass at my worst
this is if they knew who i really was
that that leave me yeah it's one of the
most basic
human fears that all of us have and yet
all of us think we're the only ones yeah
we really think we're just like well
clearly everyone else is fine yeah
showing who they really are but that's
what's going on there yeah i need my
positive attributes to outweigh
you know to make it worth it and i i
realize this about stand-up is like
because i got
i have i have gotten all of the things i
wanted in stand-up i've gotten them i
wanted a special buy 30 or at 30. that's
what i wanted so
once i
got to this place where i was like oh my
god i'm like touring theaters i have
multiple netflix specials i i did all
the things
maybe
we start looking at the other stuff
that could make you a better partner
and not just focus on like being
impressive
like maybe we we stop looking at your
credits
as a way to make people love you and
instead become like more patient and
forgiving yeah and even tempered and
communicative
and
loving and
loving to the i've been getting angry
lately i don't know why i've been on
like a little more stress or something
and this is gonna sound maybe woo-woo or
like maybe owen wilson should say it but
it's like i've been practicing when i
get angry i just go i love my anger i
love this anger like thank you
you protect me sometimes you keep me
sharp when i need to be sharp like it
doesn't need to overflow like often i'm
so waspy but i'll i'll keep it inside
but like it really dissolves it when you
greet it with understanding and even
affection you're just like because i can
love your anger like i can love taylor's
anger when i see you get worked up on
stage you're really communicating to
something powerful and strong that
you're feeling we love it it's just so
hard when we're feeling how like you
know complicated and messy it feels it's
like embarrassing yeah that's how it is
for me i'm embarrassed that i lost
control of myself it's so embarrassing
it's so embarrassing
oh yeah it's embarrassing what are we
doing here it's i don't i don't know i
don't like it yeah not a fan yeah i'm
flawed and broken yeah my biggest
insecurity uh i'm not a fan not a fan
and my my biggest insecurity is just
that like i i can handle if people leave
comments that are like this i thought
this was supposed to be funny and i'm
like this is not for you like it's funny
to some people like i'm funny but if
people are like you're ugly i'm like
you're right that's absolutely correct
and i knew it and i knew it secretly but
i know that's not true it's the same as
being funny you're like this is
subjective but
this shouldn't but like everybody has
their own individual things but it's so
embarrassing that you can to feel
like ugly like it's so embarrassing i
have a joke that i don't know i like it
so much and it's like it goes fine so
it's one of those ones where you're like
should i get rid of this i think i saw
you do it did you see me because you
said that joke just fine but i won't get
wrong no it's not that one that one i
figured out this last week and i just
had to change the wording so that one's
working but the one that i can't figure
i just don't know if i should keep or
not is like i'm so tired of trying to
figure out if i'm attractive or not like
trying to figure out if you are hot is
like trying to figure out if god is real
like even if you manage to convince
yourself
you'll never convince everybody and
you'll never know for sure wow and like
your mom thinks so but of course she
does right she has to right
that's i think that's great it's
interesting but i don't know if it's
funny there's just a speed bump i for me
i think is as soon as you tie it to
something as big as like it's probably
50 50 in the crowd believing god don't
believe in god i have this whole chunk
i'm doing on god
and at the you know how the joke ends
sorry that's not funnier that's how the
joke ends it's actually built into the
joke because i love doing it but it's
like it's like a tedx talk yeah at a
certain point not even a full ted talk
to tedx talk we're on the side stage
yeah exactly let me put this to you like
all of these things are
and i'm with i'm with you in this like
as shiny aspiring people people want to
be shiny and people who want other
people to tell us we're attractive or
funny and all this stuff even when they
do which is what you were starting to
get to it's like you've you've ticked so
many boxes that you wanted to text in
your career
you're still
separate you know what you mean like
their praise still puts you away from
them you know does that make sense right
where you're like you like the trick i
can do exactly yeah not the fullness
yeah not the person who loves your
ugliness or
you have that great ability like i love
your soft arms like we need those people
that actually i think val does love my
baby butt like i have a butt it looks
like a baby's butt i've seen it looks
like a baby's butt and she's like i
believe her when she says i love your
baby but
and
for me i need that safe person
where there's no performing which
paradoxically val and i laugh more than
anybody yeah you know what i'm saying
like but you wouldn't think i thought i
had to be all
rigid and perfect but it turns out like
you can just flop around and be stupid
and she's like like that's safe so i'm
wondering
what what's this current boy is he uh
stand up community oh i mean no no no no
i'm sorry and also i don't want to react
that way oh yeah i've dated comedians i
don't want to make it sound like that
was some horrible thing no i understand
but i think
it's absolutely two hit men it's
absolutely too i dated a comic who used
to say that like years ago in my early
20s he would say when we went on the
road he's like someone were like two
hired guns and i'm like sure yeah like
like like like like like like like like
like like like like like two years ago
there were some comedians that still
only date comedians and some married
comedians and their comedians who only
date comedians well i remember
natasha legero only only dated i think
and then she married moshe yeah she was
a very funny comedian and i remember
because i was wondering if i should date
a comedian and i end up dating a
comedian yeah and she's like it's the
best because they understand bits and
they understand clubs and for me
and that person and i are still very
close but like that's that wasn't right
for me because two hit men dating each
other it just yeah it becomes completely
normal that all you think about and all
you talk about is how to assassinate
like a brazilian
dictator yeah those are good times who
books that right who books brazilian
dictator who books that huh yeah crazy
so you're it is weird yeah yeah yeah no
i i what is weird about it you were
saying
it's weird because i i have felt that
way too where
it is so funny to me that there are
people
i and maybe this is less of a thing now
but when i was younger it felt like more
of a thing where we would all sit around
and go like i mean
who else are you gonna date who else is
gonna get it yeah no one else is gonna
get it i'm like people in the army don't
say this yeah like people who have been
to war aren't like i no one's gonna
understand where i'm coming from
unless the and it's like we're just
doing dick jokes like no one else can
south bend funny bone if you don't get
those four words i can't love you
you're right if you haven't been to cap
city i mean
there are people in platoons
doing things that most people will never
do and they don't talk to us that way no
it's so stupid we are so stupid
we're so stupid but you get to a point
where you're like oh we're just like
enabling each other's insecurities and
workaholism well that's what i that's
what i ultimately thought it was you
yeah when you're dating another comedian
not all of them clearly i think
natasha and moshe are a wonderful couple
but when i did it it was like you won't
get in my way i'm like tom cruise in
collateral
and i'm like look i'm in a cab killing
seven people in los angeles in one night
can you be my jamie foxx
and they're like i have people to kill
too
i'm you know yeah i i have a thing too i
also have a thing i'm killing six people
doesn't mean you're better than me are
you gonna drive tomorrow
so
funny
i i used to get in trouble i always
think of this because this is one of
those things that you don't realize
is a huge mistake when you're in your
20s but when you look back here like it
was but my the girl that i dated who was
a comedian was several years behind me
and she wanted to do
like a hot show in new york and i just
went up to the book and i was like you
should you should look at this person
and she was mortified i thought i was
doing the good thing yeah and she was
like you just did
my nightmare right is that you went up
and and there was like i didn't even
recognize this but there was some
condescension where i'm like well you're
not gonna get all i was thinking was
like people had done that for me like
the way i got on it was someone did it
for me i know we're dating but like
there are things the optics are just
wrong yeah i've never dated anybody that
was like
like
five years behind me or something i
don't know that i could do that yeah
like i think that would be hard and i
don't know that
i could date somebody who was like
way more successful than me i actually i
probably could but like
i i i don't know
that i could handle being someone who
was ahead yeah
and navigating that that sounds that
sounds really hard i hear you it's great
when it's like you're both kind of in
the same
oh
yeah that's awesome it's an alliance
yeah it's an alliance it's cool yeah
like this is like fan fiction yeah like
on for some people on reddit it's like
dating and other people are mad probably
it's like dating in high school you know
you're probably going to break up when
you go to college right but you're like
right now we're prom king and queen and
it's too lonely out there it's too hard
out there we need to do this together
yeah so here's a question about i'd like
to hear about your boyfriend in general
but also
in your special you said something that
i thought was really smart but you
talked about the the when you go to
enough therapy you realize it's you
remember like you're a raccoon in a bag
yeah yeah you get in the fight yeah i
was wondering just like to help people
even me
like what are the things that you
figured out about yourself like what
were those humbling things where you're
like oh wait i had this issue i had this
issue even though a lot of them are in
your spectrum i'm just wondering
like what those
moments were i mean so many i
being on mood stabilizers i feel like an
entirely different person which has been
which has been tough because i i started
on the ones i'm on now that worked for
me
a few months before i filmed quarter
life
and so that would have been mid-2019
and then i was on half the dosage i am
now for like
a year and a half and i thought i was
great and i'm like we got it
and then i had like another episode and
i was like
that's when i found out i was bipolar
too and i
once i got to this dosage it was like oh
okay this is what it is and looking back
on stuff you go
oh i i used to
pull away from people
when i felt scared and
nervous and betrayed and what retreat
yeah yeah and really just like
i used to be i think i used to be really
angry like i used to be
very suspicious
of everybody i used to expect people
to
lie to me and leave me and
all these different things that
i now realize were coming from somewhere
inside me sometimes they weren't
sometimes i was right and sometimes that
was fully happening and then kind of to
your point i think this is one of the
most interesting
undiscussed
things about relationships is what we're
unconsciously looking for like when you
say it's a self-fulfilling prophecy and
then you act a certain way to make it
happen yeah that's that is one aspect of
it i think there's this other aspect
with like what are you attracted to
and why yeah and i'm not trying to
i sure don't want you to feel sad but i
have to think with your with your mom
that's a type of abandonment right oh
yeah so you feel
almost like
like that you know when being sad is
kind of cozy i think you do yeah i do so
you kind of like are looking for what's
familiar
yeah and and maybe even being left is
the worst thing in the world but it's
also kind of like at least you know how
to navigate it right yeah the the whole
what you were talking about with
feeling like you have to earn people's
love and affection
i felt that way with my dad who is alive
but i don't speak to
so i talked to him you talked to him oh
yeah how is he doing we have a whatsapp
oh oh good okay that's great that's
great if you could uh you know change
his mind on some things that would be
great
uh
you seem like a you should you should be
there
you really are you should be a therapist
for conservative middle-aged white men
because you have the christianity vibe
to you so you can kind of sneak it in
there well you say something to me and
then i go okay i'll take that to him and
then i go to him like the u.n yeah
and then he says something to me and
then i go like well i'm not gonna say
that right
and then i change it a little bit well
let's get to that
we'll figure it out but like i think
for me
i expect to have to earn somebody's love
and that they're going to
say something
like
just crushing to me
if somebody like
showers me with praise and love but then
will say something really devastating
and horrible
and
not listen to what i'm saying or what i
need or like
all of that feels very familiar to me
because that was my relationship with my
dad yes so
that is the first part and then if
that's not the case if i feel safe and
loved and
taken care of i immediately think
they're gonna die right of course so
you got both one way or the other
nobody's sticking around right right
which is why
see i
taylor this happened last time i i
really don't want to sound
like i'm over here and i figured it out
but something that worked for me i just
remember before i met val
i had a lot of friendships actually that
were modeling uh something toxic that i
had with my mom which is very similar my
mom is very loving but then she'll also
be like well that hat is ridiculous you
know
it's like she says it and i thought i
convinced myself that i really liked
that i was like i wish my dad was like
that by the way that's not what i'm
talking about no i know i know at least
i wish it was that yeah it's worse than
that yeah no it's pretty bad yeah what
do you mean oh it's really wonderful
i'll tell you off mike but it's bad it's
brilliant
really yeah yeah yeah it's really rough
it's like we can't it's like we can't
speak to you anymore rough wow like it
has to get to a bad point yeah that was
the thing is like the
the la times called you which i'm so
sorry again that that happened to you i
said to you i was like
i hope that was okay because i directly
addressed yes how i was hoping that
maybe it would
not not just for the sake of like being
nice right you and your dad would at
some point reconcile but because that
just seems to be how things go yeah yeah
they die
and then they change like yeah that's
what we can say about the whole universe
yeah just constantly dying and changing
yeah right and that's that's what i was
like oh wouldn't it be interesting if
you're a religious dad and you had your
own sort of death and resurrection
because that's just the sine wave and if
it was just that if it was just
you know we have different religious but
i have plenty of family not plenty but i
have some family that
you know your grandparents or whatever
they believe different things
religiously but there's still that love
and yes you know and you all know and
it's okay and you just have different
opinions this is not that this is like
emotionally abusive mental illness like
this is not good so
i was trying to
speak about it very uh
you know vaguely and balanced in this
l.a times article and i think
maybe i think that interviewer was i
know that interviewer who was very
lovely was
coming from a place like he came up very
religious and related to that part we
talked for two hours and it was mostly
just about
me
well i love talking about religion
i was just going like did you know
prayer isn't just a list of things you
want it's actually a way of seeing the
world or whatever he was like we were
really vibing and we talked for you
about you just just what's in the
article yeah no when you find another
person who's like you got out i got out
and i have all these feelings about it
like that was very much how that
interview was and so of course we like
got to that and i think maybe
he thought it was more like of a
religious thing of like well we just
don't
you know i don't believe in god and
that's sad and or like i don't believe
in the christian god or like i don't
whatever
i'm the one person that you would be
like you know i i have a some
interpretation of the unknown
i know there's something else but look
the space pictures me up i wasn't
just like cool
uh how did the space pictures make you
feel great well i'll tell ya i feel like
you jerked off to the space pictures
supernova you loved it a champagne
supernova
i love the space pictures
and look let's not get off uh this topic
because i think people are here to hear
about you
but the space pictures are great and i
saw this there was a tick tock that i
really enjoyed that that valerie showed
me and it was like jesus is my lord and
savior really he went to all of these
because each one of these is like a
billion planets or something and i was
like that's why the only definition of
god
that works first of all god is just a
word that means origin it means the most
irreducible
nature of existence right so we call it
god and then it becomes all these other
things and even with jesus jesus to me
is just someone who realized his oneness
with the con the constant of being which
is beingness so when you look at a photo
like that you're like look at the
infinite potential of planets and solar
systems and stars well the only thing
that we have in common with that that's
a constant is
they are is beingness so meaning
if there is an alien species on another
planet and undoubtedly there is
they are conscious yeah you know what
i'm saying so jesus doesn't have to go
to them they are if you'll forgive some
religious language they are the christ
they are using the christ which is
awareness they're using the same
mechanism that makes me aware yes yeah i
just i just don't want to think about it
that much that's how i feel i just spent
so many years thinking about it
that wasn't fun for you i nope i don't
feel that way anymore the way i feel
about it is like yeah there's something
else isn't that cool but i'm not going
to figure it out and i don't want to do
something
i don't want to pour time and energy
into something that has no end point
like you know if i could like find the
answer i'd go look for it but there is
no answer so like
i don't want there's no answer you can
know
you're not you're not gonna like it
there's only answers you can become
that's very you're like it's not it's
all good you're you're really in a
productive good place and like i think
when the sediment
settles the lake gets clearer and that's
just not where we're at right look when
i do mushrooms i feel great
i feel like did mushrooms oh yeah doing
mushrooms feels great that's the only
time i feel like
it's just all of it man like we're just
all here and it's great and it's all the
same stuff well that's exactly my point
yeah but i don't feel that way all the
time the rest of the time i'm just like
i can't think about this too much i
gotta otherwise i i go to nothing
matters really quickly now
and then it makes it hard for me to get
motivated to do things
well i think the meaning of life is is
life including the moments where you go
nothing matters i think in that moment
you are the universe having the
experience of
this and that's as valid as
anything okay yeah all right you wanted
to do it yeah i mean taylor i feel bad
now because maybe you don't want to talk
this way but i'm like if there was one
thing that we could call god that split
into a billion not even a billion
billions and billions and billions and
billions and billions and millions of
things because it wanted to know what it
was like to be a seashell and it wanted
to know what it was like to be
in a comedian estranged to her father
once it wanted to play
every game and that'll never make sense
to our
mind because we don't want to think it's
a a game but it's it's just it's so in
love with experience and exploration and
expansion that like even when you're
like
here's an alan watts quote right he goes
an atheist is the greatest of god's
creations because it's god got so lost
in its own game that it stopped
believing in itself
it's actually the most
sublime art piece yeah can you imagine
if it's like a painting became
self-aware and was like nothing painted
me that's br that's amazing
yeah that's like whoa
it's so
its own thing that it cut itself from
the
it flew away from the falconer
completely it's just a falcon
it's just a free falcon you see a free
falling like jesus christ like it's
pretty great well let me go back can i
tell you why i told you that thing about
like if there's life on other planets
like
why that's not just a thought experiment
it's actually something that makes me
feel yeah less panic when i see the
space photos yes is because
anything that's happening there is
happening
on the same screen that that this is
happening meaning
if this will either do it for you or it
won't
but your experience is known right
something knows your experience
like your eyes are taking in this
information but there's something that
registers it mm-hmm and we could just
call that consciousness
and that i would say is another
understanding of god god says i am that
i am he's saying i am emness so it's the
thing that's ready so even if there is
an alien over there
he's that or it is operating with the
same
consciousness that's the one constant no
matter how many universes there are no
matter how many planets there are no
matter how many deviations of life there
are all of life in that being would be
known with the same consciousness that i
am known and that you could call god
that's that's what we mean that the
pursuit of the spiritual is looking for
what doesn't change it doesn't matter if
you're tripping on mushrooms or having
this conversation with me right now or
if you're happy or sad or five years old
or 45 years old the thing that knows
your awareness never changes that's why
i'm 43 i don't feel any older that's me
getting in touch with the fact that
there's a constant and the thing that's
constant
is
i mean you can close your eyes where
does this end close your eyes and ask
yourself is there something you don't
have to but is there i'll do it is there
something
is there a boundary when i'm looking at
my own awareness is there a boundary on
the other side of which this this
awareness isn't
i think i'm just dumb you're not dumb
i'm not explaining it well
i'm trying to get you in touch with your
own
infinity i
what i like
i like you said i think i'm just dumb
here's what i like i think we're on the
deepak chopra network and you're trying
to bring it back to comedy i like to
just go
i don't know
that that was what feels most
comfortable to me because it took me
years to get there i think for years i
was like no it's god and it's jesus and
like okay i don't understand this is how
i make sense of that okay you created
the world and it's of it like there was
just so much of that that now i just
kind of live for the moments whether
you're in nature or i'm like with my
siblings where i just feel that like oh
there's something bigger like there's
there is meaning there's something
important about this
that is that is as spiritual as i
like to feel like that's how i like to i
like to feel like there's some meaning
all of that makes me feel like there's
none
where i'm like well if it's just
it's cool i guess but like
if this doesn't matter
really
on a core level like why am i doing it
you know just for fun like i want to get
to that place i'd love to get to that
place next where i just go like that's
just fun we're just having fun this is
fun let's go do that like oh i'm in pain
right now that's a different thing
that's a different experience yeah like
that's like the best
situation where you like go through a
heartbreak and it's like interesting to
you or you're like i've never been this
hurt
like it's like this is a different kind
of
pain and emotional
like
what and it's why you like watch movies
of
exactly people going through heartbreak
he's like oh i connect to this now i get
this now or like why people have babies
because they're like oh this like opened
up
another part of my brain and like this
new level of love that i got to that i
want to experience like that thing
you're talking about with whatever god
is wants to experience everything like i
feel that way as a woman where i'm like
i would like to have children but i
would like to adopt and i'd also like to
be pregnant and i'd like to i just like
to feel all the things out of
you know curiosity and a desire for
the full experience
of experiences that i want to have i
don't want to have every experience some
of them are painful and scary and hard
but the ones that i do want to have i'd
like to get to all of them
that's interesting to me and i like
talking about that but i
i don't like going to
that
very like nihilistic place of like what
are we who cares
i sure yeah i i don't feel like it's who
cares you don't feel like that no okay
that's what you got from me saying
that's where yeah operates on
consciousness i was trying to say like
it's all one party oh okay that maybe i
misunderstood i was panicking in my head
where i'm just like yeah no there's
we're so small
that's why i just feel like i'm just an
aunt i feel like when i saw those space
pictures yeah i felt like an ant
carrying a big piece of cookie on my
back
and
everyone's like look it's so big it's
we're so small down here isn't that cool
and i'm like
no it's not cool why are we carrying
this cookie
over here and they're like because then
the cookie will be over there and it's
we're still ants down here that's we're
still ants but yeah there's a lot of
other bigger stuff and we're just really
small and i'm like
just i hope then someone just stepped on
me
like
you know what i mean
i totally know what you mean i have
moments like that yeah i don't just walk
around
holding it all together at all
i deal with that all the time i'm just
saying
the cleanest way i can say what i'm
saying is no matter what is anywhere
the operating system is the same and
it's all consciousness
it's all
if there's something that's conscious
somewhere even if it's just an ecosystem
even if it's just plant life or water
it's all
being known with the same mechanism that
i'm own meaning what does that mean what
that's what i was trying to say it's not
just a thought experiment it's me saying
i belong here
i'm not a visitor here hmm
again alan watts says we're not like
people say you came into the world when
you were born you came into the world
like taylor showed up into the world he
said a better way to say it would be you
came out of the world meaning it's all
one thing that's the cliche of the
spiritual be one with the universe it's
all one thing i don't i see photos
you could get pretentious and say i saw
photos of myself i saw the photo of the
only thing that's happening
it's all relative distance they're small
we're big it's like
medium only exists in relation to small
and large if you have a medium ice cream
and you walk out of the store it's not a
medium ice cream it's just the size that
it is you know what i'm saying like and
we're only small in relation to them
it's all together
it's like i'm at home here i'm not a
mistake
they're me i'm them it's all it's it's
just a way of making me feel less
anxious i suppose okay as opposed to
going like i'm just this and
they make me irrelevant they're it's the
same thing which some people like that
some people like going oh my god i'm so
small and nothing matters and that's
great some people feel that way yeah i i
don't know i think it's both i think
it's a paradox it's like
it's like i think the space pictures
were a rorschach test
hilarious
you saw what you want to see for sure
but i think i i think
yes i think it's both meaningless and
the most meaningful i think this
conversation we're having right now is
the most meaningful thing in the world
and it's also
as the buddhists would say it's on fire
it's gone mm-hmm eve it doesn't matter
that we film it at some point those will
be gone but that's what i'm saying it's
like
this is what someone in their car is
having a panic attack right now
listening to this yeah just pulling up
no i'm gonna eat the arby's now yeah
just who gives a it's really
because like do you feel that way
i was talking to i was talking to zach
about this last night before i went on
stage
where i was like do you ever just feel i
think he might have said really to her
just feel like
so crazy that everyone's just like
sitting there watching you talk
like there's just 500 people in this
room right now just like
he's like oh my god he's like people put
on makeup and they just came to sit here
yes and listen to us
talk talk
it's so weird he's like if somebody just
like he's like if some other thing did
come watch it they'd be like why
i think this if you could take one
person out of an audience and put them
in like the the mac commercials room
just so all white matrix room yeah and
and we can't hear the audio of the
comedian and we just hear what you said
[Laughter]
four you know just like distract like
that's pure insanity for sure yeah that
makes sense to me yeah but everything is
i mean
okay
it's really tempting to just only talk
about spiritual things it's like
my brain is swollen right now there's a
relief in going
it's both it's like
you're the most precious thing in the
world who you really are but all these
thoughts and feelings and emotions and
memories isn't what you it wasn't what
you really are because when you were a
baby you were as you as you are i
disagree really yeah you think well you
i don't think you were as you as you are
we hadn't built the thing called taylor
yet yeah but i'm saying that thing that
you built that we go around insisting
that we are sure there's some constants
in there there's your personality and
your preferences and stuff we could say
that's real but a lot of that shifts
like those those beliefs change uh
taylor who's a christian has changed
taylor who is this taylor who's not good
at stand-up has changed you know what
i'm saying like now we have taylor who
is good at stan so yeah the interesting
thing and the thing that we can
rest in and feel peaceful in
is the only thing that was consistent
that whole time do you feel connected to
who you were as a child
i feel like the same thing you feel like
the same thing so you at like eight you
feel like the same thing
i am the same thing and you feel it
yes that's interesting and then other
times i go like god now i have to reply
to all these business emails and
i lose it yeah but this by the way look
to any myth for other examples of this
they're always trying to get something
back
yeah you know what i mean they need to
go on a quest and regain their innocence
the fountain of youth or the holy grail
we want to get back to that place where
we were less encumbered where there were
less things in between our true nature
and you know our experience because
that's where peace is you can repeat
like when you take mushrooms i i think
what happens is a lot of the story
dissolves
to that why don't you tell me until
instead of me telling you about your
mushroom experience why don't you tell
me about what what happened when did you
do them for the first time i did them
for the first time
i guess it was 20 20. yeah it was
probably 20 or 20. okay nine months ago
not that long ago during the pan
yeah and we just went outside okay um
and my friend chelsea's done them a lot
and she was like i think you'd like them
and so we did them and i was like
where
huntington gardens in pasadena
i mean i'm a member
so am i yeah i've also
tripped
it's the perfect place there are
bathrooms yep there's a cafe a lot of
bathrooms yeah but you're also there's
extensive grounds we me and my friend
had high tea you know how you can have
yes and it started kicking in while we
were at t and i was like talk about your
friends feeling that's kind of a
synchronicity i was like this is
ridiculous we're like shaved apes
sitting around eating tiny sandwiches
being like
what do you think of the tea you know it
was
totally a joke but not
i keep imposing my my beliefs on it not
like a bad joke a hilarious joke like
look at what we're doing look at the
game we're playing now so you you did
them where where did they start kicking
in just because i know they started
kicking in uh in that stretch by the all
the statues in the fountain okay that
stretch and we said
the rose garden yeah no that's not the
rose garden the rose gardens a little
further i'm talking about the one with
the the
just the long lawn
and at the end is the fountain and it's
lined with statues we always go another
route we don't know oh i see yeah we go
you go through the like villa yep yes
more members we're members
huntington.org yes
so good so worth it oh yeah we go all
the time oh my god all the time when you
have a baby if you do if you have a baby
you go you take your kid there amazing
place to bring a baby that place makes
me want to have a baby no that's where
you go to get real you'll ovulate
oh my god it becomes an ovulation what
do you think when people are like you
shouldn't have babies right now because
everything's going to
i save a bit about that i'm like do you
think the scientists that are saying the
world's going to end in 20 years are
they having babies like i just asked the
audience do you think they're having
babies
some of them i i
i'm sure some of them are having i'm
sure some of them are too because no
matter what and i think there's
something really beautifully human going
on there
in almost like uh it's almost like star
trek you know how star trek's like in a
utopia where we figured everything out
we tend to find a way other
civilizations have gone away i'm not
saying it's a guarantee
and there's a good chance that we will
go away too but there's always this hope
that that's like one of the like if
aliens were studying us they'd be like i
never ceased to be amazed by your hope
even in the face of like
horrible data yeah that's why i think
some of those scientists are having
babies interesting yeah but i'd love to
i'd love the data i'd love to are you
nervous as a someone who's a parent of a
young child
i'll answer in a bit it's like you
climbed a mountain to talk to a comedian
let me answer in a bit
i think it's funny this never works i go
i think it's funny that people are
afraid of flying uh because the plane
might crash and i'm like but we're
always in these airplanes and then i put
my arms out like you're never not on an
airplane yeah you know what i mean like
yeah when you're in an airplane yeah
you're in an airplane but when you're on
the ground you're in these airplanes and
you're the pilot and you keep
eating cake and cholesterol full of food
like
there's danger yeah so like yes there
are new dangers but like there was a
time that you and i
we wouldn't have been recording it we
would have been having a chat under a
cherry blossom tree and would think
genghis khan might come and chop our
heads off you know what i mean like
there's just
living in threat of elimination is not
a new thing to human beings right
so
now you've caught me being like i don't
i don't spend too much time thinking
about that as much as i'm like
oh we could die
what kind of what else is new we should
do everything we can to protect other
people and protect my my family and
protect my friends and all and although
every the whole world but i'm also i
don't spend too much time being like
i don't know i remember when trump won
and people were like
it's all gonna you know and a lot of bad
things did happen but not the things
they were saying in that green room um
right in that career yeah yeah
yeah what do you think
what do i think about you having kids no
no what do you think about
do you worry about the planet ending and
all that um when i worry i drink liquid
death
thank you
yeah no i i think
i have such bad anxiety that i worry
about everything all the time so it just
gets really overwhelming to me
and i have to just stay focused on
like what i have to do today
and like come up with a new goal to have
and
figure out how to make meaning of things
because again it's really easy for me to
just slip into like
i don't want to be
i get exhausted by my fear
and i don't want to feel that way
anymore and i just don't want to feel
anything i just i'm like i can't
i it's too much and it's too hard and
it's too painful
and sometimes that is very liberating
and you just go like i just don't care
and i'm fine i'm just gonna choose to
enjoy this and then other times it sends
you into like a very deep depression of
like
i don't
you know
like i do feel that way i feel that way
when people say um
why are you having kids
when
the world's gonna end et cetera
and i kind of feel like why yeah why are
we doing anything still
if it's just gonna end like it's not
specific to kids like why are we doing
any of this right
yeah
val and i we're i'm always trying to
work on this bit where it's like
explaining life to my child yeah it's
like well there's um theme parks and
there's
there's candy and there's ooh lobster
you'll like lobster
we all die one day
um you just slip that in between lobster
and theme parks yeah we i don't know how
to make it work but that's sort of the
deal yeah um
and we really don't like that we want to
put our names on buildings and we want
to yeah have statues but i know what you
mean that some of my the voice of some
of my sadness can be like who cares that
there's a statue of walt disney here
yeah you know what you mean like it
doesn't make a difference to him here's
a question
because
you don't seem like
you feel like this now maybe i'm wrong
and you do
but you seem very you know sort of
evolved and spiritual and on a higher
level and like you just want to be happy
above everything else but when you were
younger coming up in comedy were you
like i want to be the greatest of all
time yeah okay do you still feel that
way no
that's okay that doesn't that kind of
suck
but do you miss it no because i think i
am one of the greats i don't know okay
yeah i don't know if you you feel like
you did it you made it i only say this
because the difference becomes who's
telling you you're shiny okay and then
we're back to the beginning of our
conversation and i know it's absurd to
say i think i'm one of the greats but i
watch i watch the greats and then i
watch what i'm doing and i go
i'm doing what they're doing you know
what i mean that that's my that
you could wait for
aforementioned vulture to say pete
holmes is one of the greats uh-huh or
you could just go ahead and be like
you know what i'm meeting my own
standard like i'm doing oh
okay and it's i mean but it really helps
to have like a family and you can come
home
little sweetie kisses so there's
different altitudes to fly at right and
now we're in the middle there's the
spiritual one which i'm gonna stop doing
because it's not really helping anybody
the comments are like taylor doesn't
like it stop
stop god explaining
no taylor does like it well we did talk
a lot about it last time and it was
interesting i'm curious to see where
you're at no no no i'm curious to see
where you're i wouldn't know leave any
comment you want leave any comment you
want we don't care speaking of nothing
matters right your comment certainly
doesn't barking into a void
barking into a void except every once in
a while the nice ones the guy who posts
them joe will say like look this guy
posted this really nice one that is nice
there you go
uh what were we saying
oh we were talking about wanting to be
the greatest of all time what i'm saying
is what i find interesting about
spiritual pursuits and i think this is
really going to speak to you is i find
it paradoxical the more that i meet my
my needs my psychological needs all that
stuff that i was just dismissing the the
false self the peep that's just a a
matrix of memories and feelings and
opinions and preferences
past experiences and fears and all that
stuff that i think is me i was so
dismissive of that and going like that's
all on fire who cares okay well let's
change altitudes that matters like
meeting my needs exercising meeting my
needs meditating meeting my needs with
my family meeting my needs creatively
making sure i do stand up at least x
number of times in a month or whatever
it might be
there's no more beautiful spiritual time
for old pd then after he had a great set
what what is going on there
meaning it's not a flaw i don't think
it's a mistake playing taylor the game
tailor to an optimum place and getting
in that state of flow where you're like
this is what i was meant to do which is
how i feel when i watch you do stand-up
for example you found it you're you're
not pushing the river you're just going
along with the ride and you're serving
people i know you probably don't want to
hear that but like people are sad people
are lonely people all these things and
there we are val and i had a good old
hearty heart watching it and laughing at
things things that maybe are hard to say
it's beautiful that's a gift and when
you're in that frequency that's when i
tend to be a little bit more like it's
all okay it's all okay so you know what
i'm saying yeah we don't have to dismiss
it
uh so anyway back to your to your thing
about unless you had a thought on that
no i kind of i'm just
i'm deciding whether or not to ask this
because it's such a hacky question but
i'm going to it
did you feel
that when you got really happy and
settled were you afraid that you were
going to get worse
as a stand-up initially was that an
initial fear of yours that you then just
at a certain point we're like oh no
we're fine right well
i think it's an okay question i don't
think it's a hacky question i mean
it goes back to what i so a lot of the
relationships before remember i was
starting to say were remodeled after
what i thought was appropriate because
of how my mom was to me the example i
always use and again this is why we
stopped talking about it because we
started talking about how terrible your
dad can be but my mom just little things
like that's a gaudy watch or whatever
right so i would look for people that
would say that's a gaudy watch and
that's fine because that's what i
thought i deserved yeah you know what
i'm saying
uh and then i met val
and i found somebody who i loved and who
loved me just for who i was and took no
effort yeah the test was always like are
you more yourself with them than when
you're not and that's not always right
away but like you ease into that yeah
and then
she thought i was so funny and then i
was like i'm just gonna be like this i'm
just gonna and then and then you have
that safety net under you again which is
like it contributes to the fearlessness
and it contributes to my ability to go
like i think i'm doing
great
because val is modeling a higher
vibration a higher standard of love does
that make sense so you go on stage a
little more fearlessly because you're
not trying to win it
that's really nice
yeah that's really cool yeah is that
hopeful that's super hopeful oh good i
love that that makes up for all that
space you said earlier yeah we're
all just space and we're all the same
matter and
that's why nothing does i didn't say i
know you didn't i'm kidding i'm twisting
your words i'm twisting your words um
but no that is that is very helpful
because you do
i think a lot of people worry about that
i think and myself included is like well
once i'm like really happy and i have a
family and i'm yeah do you have that one
settled with medication because that's
and that's i did a good question i had
that with medication too i think
i was glad that
i felt like i had something to say once
i figured out the medication stuff so
that helped
but like the last
last may is when everything happened
and so it's been it's been a year
of me no no no of me being well also
that but it's been uh it's been a year
of me being on like the right amount of
medication and knowing exactly what i
need and what's going on
and i do feel very different and it has
been a full year since i've had any like
hypomania and that has been something
that i
really
had to like mourn the loss of
because i looked back at my 20s and i
looked back at so many
moments
in my 20s
that
those episodes were really like
helpful in terms of like
being really motivated and like
like really nailing something whether it
was like a taping or whatever and like
it would be
but you also have to remember the other
side of it which is like i was also like
destroying personal relationships at the
same time like it wasn't
it wasn't all just good but it is this
incredible feeling of like it's like
having the most self-esteem in the world
and
hypomania isn't as intense as mania so
hypomania you can like
just feel like well i'm just really
productive and i'm just really motivated
and like we talk for a living so you can
just like kind of tell everybody why
what you're doing makes sense and it's
great and they're like oh okay all right
yeah okay i guess that makes sense even
if they're like that seems
fast or like a lot or also because it
makes money people won't
oh yeah people yeah as long as it works
it's okay right exactly even if it's not
mentally helpful i i felt that way um
and in relationships too like every time
i started a relationship i was
generally uh now looking back um
in a hypomanic state
and
i just i i'm relating really hard yeah
in my first marriage
we moved upstate
and val and i have a term for we call it
mania even though it's not diagnosed uh
oh we call it manic i just say just so
you know i'm manic right now
uh meaning i'm aware that i'm i call it
infinite potential my brain just lights
up like christmas
uh don't pitch me a movie because i'll
make it and i'll make it yeah
i'll write it sometimes i'll write
something really i've got three cameras
in here
we can do it
katie brought a bounce
um
we but like i just had to become aware
uh that that's a dangerous state in the
sense that i'll agree
to things or i'll plan things and the
example that i was about to give you was
i didn't know when in my first marriage
this is noteworthy i didn't know that i
was sometimes manic there was no
vocabulary for that and i agreed to move
upstate which was a terrible idea for me
when i was manic because i remember i
had just come home from doing a set and
i was like and i think that same day
isn't this sweet it's like one of those
early early achievements i had met
someone who like knew a commercial agent
who was going to get me a meeting
i'm on the launch pad man let's do this
from sleepy hollow new york and it was
like terrible and then when i crashed
yeah and i don't crash as hard as i'm up
that might be delusional but i tend to
go really up and then i tend to just go
to like a normal feeling low but it is
low um i'm like what have i done i don't
understand what i did so i i relate
i just don't want you to feel alone in
this i think a lot of creative people
relate and i know what you're saying
where it's like you get level but then
you miss that you maybe miss writing a
um an entire novel
in 48 hours right because you're just
if you stop you might burn up or
something like you might vanish right
but then yeah the flip side of that is
like canceling three weeks of work
because you can't
get on an airplane
without scream crying you know like it's
just like did that happen
oh yeah there were i had to just cancel
it was getting worse and worse and i
just
had to like
i had to like cancel like scream crying
and interact that's great i wasn't
scream crying on an airplane like i was
wearing at home and couldn't stop and
was just like i have to just
say i'm sick or something and i just
can't do it and you can edit anything
out
it's interesting to me people don't talk
that way like when we talk about mental
difficulties or whatever you want to
call them
i just like putting a label to like
scream crying is interesting to me i
don't hear people talking about that i
don't hear people talking about you
mentioned panic attacks and stuff yeah
full i think i'm gonna die
yeah there are there have been several
nights like that where like the last
a year ago the crash that happened
after like my last like hypomanic
episode which during which i like got an
apartment in new york and was just like
you know very like i can do it
and uh yeah yeah you just went online
and rented an apartment uh i was i was
in my flight had gotten
my flight was canceled and i got stuck
in new york overnight
and i was in a hotel and i was
going through some stuff and i just went
i got like two hours of sleep and just
made all these appointments at like
three in the morning to go see and i was
flying out at two and i made all these
i'm having a panic attack right now no
disrespect but that is really freaking
me out yeah and i went and looked at
like four apartments
from like 7 a.m to like 11
and before i went to the airport
and
just like
was like i'm doing this and in between
each appointment i called like
everybody in my life and just told them
how great it was that i was doing it and
why it was a great idea and everybody
was like okay yeah that's you know sure
and
the next week and there's a bunch of
other stuff that happened but uh like
what oh you know just like i was just oh
yeah oh you
know rented a bad girl costume i found a
little crime yeah yeah i just like i
spent the entire flight home from new
york like
uh
just like on
i was like well just
did go on i just like got on a dating
app for like five hours the entire
flight home and went on like 10 dates in
a week and i don't date i'm like not
someone who dates i like i'm just in
relationships but i was like i can
do this this is easy and it was
and uh you know that's not and then like
a week later like
crashed and i talked to my uh
i talked to my therapist about it and
she goes okay sounds like maybe you had
some like hypomania going on i said
what's that and she goes oh i don't want
to freak you out it's only if it lasts
longer than like
three maybe four days and i said oh it
was like
like seven or eight for sure and i did
all this stuff and she was like okay
yeah we should probably talk to your
psychiatrist then
so what does the hypo mean i don't know
i think it just means like it's just a
way of differentiating
between bipolar one and two
you're asking me a question i don't i
don't technically know i was all good i
never i felt i've never been like why is
it hypo like i don't know it's just
different i think it's just a way of
saying it's different than mania because
from what i have been told and i think
that means it's allergenic oh that's
what it oh okay
because i can't not know it means it's
very clean and pure yeah
did you get the apartment yeah i still
have it
yeah cause i was like we're just gonna
make the best of this and there's a
reason i'm doing it and it's fine that i
did it and i'm gonna do it and it's
great and i don't i don't hate that i
did it like i could have not done it
absolutely for sure but like
i am like
most of the decisions i made
during these episodes i was able to spin
it
you know afterward or later
and
and sometimes it motivated me to do
things i should have done also so it's
like not black and white i couldn't be a
relating harder can i can i make a
comparison yes whenever i watch a cult
documentary they always they really do
they edit out all the parts where
they're like
let's call it the cause the cause got me
sober and i actually you know gay like
lost weight and gained all this money
and i met my wife and then they're like
but that guy was an you know but
they
i feel like they cut out the first part
because we don't do well human beings
don't do well with these stories that
require a certain level of subtlety like
subtle thinking which is what you're
doing which is like okay i'm not getting
an apartment but there's kind of and
look i'm gonna take it out of you
i like that state even though sometimes
i move upstate with my ex-wife right
right yeah exactly and like what do we
do with that yeah there's a i would i
would go
i just realized oh this is like a
pattern
throughout my 20s where i would like
break up with somebody
and then
like days later be in a new relationship
essentially like just so little time in
between that's the infinite potential of
it it is you can do this and you're
because you're like
i'm gonna be fine so i can get out of
this and i'm at my most attractive and
confident and my career is going amazing
like like you were just
it's it feels great even when you're in
like a mixed episode where you're like
also maybe like
it's just it's mania is like really hard
on your body like oh yeah even when you
feel like great you're also just like
really irritable and you're like
upset and it's not all like it's not
like totally pleasant but the highs are
so
like i have such vivid memories of it
like
one of like the darkest
like 2019 the summer of 2019 was like
one of the darkest periods of my life
but i was
it began with like hypomania
and i remember walking down the street
after
a set at the cellar
just feeling like and like i was like
destroying my relationship i was just
like
not in a good space and feeling like on
top of the world and just going like i
have my whole life ahead of me and i'm
gonna be amazing i'm the one of the best
of all time and i'm incredible and i'd
had this amazing set and i was just like
new york's incredible and like
it's hard to
miss that and also feel like oh is that
just not real like that wasn't that was
like an imbalance that was like a
chemical imbalance in my brain
i know now
and i know
now how everything happened and how i
shouldn't have handled certain things
and it's just like
it's been a very it's something i'm
still untangling honestly and making
peace with and
again sort of mourning it's like it
feels like college where like i know i
didn't have like a college experience
really so when people talk about college
where they're like oh my god i was
incredible and amazing i could never do
that again right like that was not
healthy but it was incredible at the
time and i have such great memories val
and i were talking about that last night
because we went to a party and we're
like we're the lame parents like we're
super lame and we were like i wouldn't
trade it for the world yeah uh here's a
here's an interesting idea
cause
again going back to how how others see
us and and and how we see ourselves and
and you know you and i both can have
moments where like i remember and
all that stuff yeah i just wonder if
that
and i'm not saying you need the mania
but i do think you need to like counter
balance
the tailor that's like i'm not
i have a big head or whatever that's
from your act yeah you know whatever
your self-doubt is
i do think it's natural and necessary to
have times where you go like
i'm one of the greats that's why i miss
i don't have that anymore that's that's
what i'm saying i don't think you need
the mania but you might want to look oh
god i almost recommended loving-kindness
to you
but like there's certain
forget meditation forget any spiritual
practice but there are
there's something to say
about like if it's after you brush your
teeth
looking in the mirror and saying
killing it you know what i mean
that works it's embarrassing but it
works i think i can feel that way where
i go everything's going really great
like i think
i think i am
a successful
hard-working comedian
and
but i don't i don't know how to get back
into that headspace of like
not that i ever felt like i'm the
greatest of all time but i was like i
could be
someday and i feel like i lost that when
i
leveled out and now i'm just like you're
very successful but there's always
somebody better or just as good and it's
so subjective and it's hard to say and
who's to say anyone's the greatest of
all time and who are you to think that
like
all of that has sort of
just
again evened out the
and i missed that that high of like i'm
going to be
on the mount rushmore of comedy
well i think he will be for sure
i'm not just saying that we watched it
we were like i know you don't like this
so i'll say it to the box over there
it was flawless it's very nice it really
was flawless and i and because envy is
one of the best compliments i was really
watching it going like
because i can have thoughts where i oh
i'm one of the greats and i can also
have the thoughts where i'm like
i got it i i paused it
opened up my word doc my stand-up word
doc and made notes
about
two bits
that should be together because there's
a theme between them because i was
watching you the way that you were so it
wasn't focused no no no no no
you were doing
something that i was like i should be
doing that oh i see what you're saying
you were bringing up a theme and then
you'd sort of deviate to go to that
theme and then you'd come back to the
thing and it was like
like really that's so nice yeah like i
really think envy isn't always ugly envy
is just like a really true
honest that's so good i want it
right you know what i mean it wasn't
ugly i was like i don't want you to have
it i was like inspired i was uh selena
gomez i was silly i was selena gomez i
was like truly she can do it and when i
watch great santa i saw andrew santino
not not to dilute your compliment but i
saw andrew santino i followed him uh not
that long ago and he was up there giving
so zero that i was like oh right we
can give zero i just watched you're
able to i just watched dave for the
first time and that show made me feel
that way
i did watch david tell on tour with
burton that also was like oh my god but
uh i watched the show dave and santino's
on it and he's so good in it oh okay and
you're like oh my god i should get
better at acting that uh that's that was
one of my questions what were you gonna
say i'm sorry i don't want to cut you
off uh
what was he gonna say oh i was gonna say
seeing your uh
well first up dave is such a good show
and i was like oh my god this made me
feel i to watch dave oh my god it's so
good it's one of the best comedies i've
ever seen really yeah it's so good edit
all of this out they didn't i don't
recall getting a check from fx for those
truly so good i'm writing it down dave
it's really really good uh and i thought
of it because he brought up santino and
he's in it and he's very good in it um
but i felt that way watching you because
i i never see you do stand-up live like
i did your largo show once yeah and that
was cool but that was a while ago yeah
do the next one i would love to do the
next one that's not me fishing to do
your largo show but this is how it's
booked that's absolutely like oh that's
how we do it it's like it's a real
cringe
at a certain point you know yeah like
i've noticed on instagram you've been
posting more clips lately yeah um which
i
really uh enjoy because you're like
oh yeah like cause you just once you are
one of the greats as you've said about
yourself
like truly though like once you're at a
certain level you're like oh i don't
have to be like you don't have to put
out clips yeah like you don't have
people are going to come see you if
you're like you know what i mean like
you don't have to do all this stuff
we're doing down here
like
you know
so like you don't
you you don't have that same and i feel
this way too after this second special
came out i was like i can maybe chill
for a minute
but after the first one i was like i
gotta put out another one to prove the
first one wasn't a fluke you've put out
so much material at this point that like
you can tour forever and people will
come see you
and that's a level not a lot of people
get to that's a very like that is a one
percent of comedy but as a result you
know you haven't put out a special in a
while that i've watched right it's been
a while right and so seeing you and
seeing you live is different than clips
and specials anyway and so seeing you
live was so fun because it just like
it like rocketed me back and i think i
said this to you like back to like
college because your
first album came out
my
senior year of high school
and
uh not to date myself i'm 22. um
but i
i love when young people do that
came out my senior year of high school
and i remember quoting it in
college to friends like i like had all
my friends in college listen to it and
we would quote it all the time and like
dustin and i still quote
some of your jokes i realized because i
was like i wanna i went back through and
was looking at it this morning going i
got to tell them which bits specifically
and then i was like oh dustin and i
still do
where's tom petty from
on the sometimes where we go
that whole bit about you just didn't
know yeah is so funny i'm sorry i'm
quoting your own bits your hat is gone
bradley like these are the things
bradley
your hat is gone bradley
you just had a banana i can't believe
i'm also enjoying this but i haven't
thought of that joking must be free like
there were so many bits on that album
that were so quotable and we still do it
and that's how you met your wife
like that's right these are the and look
doesn't i do our own bits to each other
too but uh yeah so i was just like oh i
did that in college and i was like we
still do that wow isn't that fun it's
the best and that that's what i was
trying to say like when i'm like people
need what what you're doing when i when
val and i say selena gomez now you know
what i'm saying you want to permeate
someone's
life right you want to become a bit that
they do to one another yeah and that
still
really makes me happy so thank you for
saying yeah so anytime we're like i
don't
who's that what is it where's tom petty
from yeah
and a shout out to brian regan who i'm
like that's very brian regan oh where's
i know but he's got
brian riggins got so many lines like
that too that you just love to say out
of context the big yellow one is the sun
yes the big yellow one is the sun
i just said very solemnly
the yellow one is the sun well he's he's
i mean i think the greatest see that's
my point do people put regan on the yeah
one of the greats i mean we do
but like time magazine or whoever the
authorities do i don't know who's the
authority but that's what i'm saying
they're going to say rock chappelle
i think brian regan is up there for sure
i don't know for us i don't know what
i'm i was trying to say i bet if he's
not i'm definitely terrified for myself
well people who know and brian regan i
think has to know that he's one of the
best that's what you say but that's
that's the corner that i feel like i
turned which is like
i'm not i'm no longer waiting for
someone to tell me
that that's remember right yes that's
good going i'm still trying to not be
uncomfortable with the fact that i said
that but i actually don't i'm just
forecasting that i might feel
uncomfortable that i said that that's
fair well there's so many
you just i don't know i'm at this point
now where i just know so many comedians
and i know how many of them are good
that it i think that's also part of why
it's hard for me to feel that way
because you just know how many good
comedians there are
and like
yeah the mount rushmore of comedy you're
like i guess kevin hart's probably like
for if we're talking about like what
most people
think it's like
who's mount rushmore of comedy comedians
mount rushmore of comedy the general
public's mount rushmore of comedy
stand-up comedy
a comedian being interviewed
like you you have different answers
totally different you should sometimes
you want to shine a light over here over
there you can't just say the same for
people so you have your people that you
say i'll make you feel better about
having a moment of self-esteem i have a
friend who started dating a guy and she
goes he's a really big stand-up comedy
fan and i said really and she goes yeah
he didn't know who you were though and i
was like then he's not really a big
stand-up comedy fan like i had that
isn't that so up i am that at
that point where i'm like if you're like
a huge stand-up comedy fan i'm in the
conversation you don't have to like me
and she goes i go who does he like and
she goes he likes bill burr i said
everyone likes bill burr and
then she goes his favorite is tommy john
again and i went okay so you know
so he's a really he is a big stand-up
comedy fan and i'm just
it changed that fast
he does like tommy johnny
i'm like no he knows he knows what good
is
not that bill bird's not good but he's
just bill burr is like it's like someone
going like i live in and out and you're
like we all love in and out right shut
up like you're not this great aficionado
of stand-up like i like going to movies
on the weekends yeah he's like bill burr
is so good he's the avengers now like
everybody loves bill burr yeah and then
to be like no i really like this amazing
comedian too that you're like oh okay
all right so you you know a lot about
stand-up comedy actually and it's just
me that's it
i'll post more clips i get it
speaking of clips you have to know the
time that's a great clip that's a great
clip i'm sorry to be transparent but
instead of
joe our guy just scouring two hours just
post that that was hilarious i i noticed
some bill did my i mentioned he did my
largo and
this is bill
try and agree with everything i'm saying
and no
bill says no
to start every sentence
i'll give you an example just like
mirror me like you're on a bad date uh
like you know just agree and say back to
me what i'm saying okay you know what i
mean
you go to the supermarket there's like
four cereal aisles now
yeah
there's like four cereal yeah there's
four star like yeah yeah he has to say
even if you're just saying like yeah
that's a lot of cereal no really you're
going it's like
someone unseen in the room
is disagreeing with
he was like i thought it was good no
that movie was good nah people are
on it it's like
what is happening
that's something you're letting another
thing in the room that's so funny um
there's so much can i ask you the
generous question please i think this is
generous let's see if i can remember
so you go
you have that joke where it's like
instead of saying you are a bipolar you
can say i have by mhm right this is just
a little behind the joker's studio god
shoot me in the face no shoot me in the
face put a graphic on that
this is just a little behind the joker
studio
brought to you by liquid i
just as a joke crafter i know you love a
lens crafter and a joke crafter
here's how the joke goes in my more ego
your my therapist said if it makes you
feel better you can say you
have bipolar instead of you are bipolar
you go that's a little bit like someone
saying no i was saying you were being a
right right
that's the joke uh-huh and it's very
lean it's like toro sushi
no fat on it it's real good when you
first did it
can you i was wondering if there was a
process because it seems to me the first
time you do that joke you go that's like
someone when they say i didn't say you
are a i'm saying you're being a
bit
am i right is there was there a process
and then you were like can i get away
with just saying because it's very lean
yeah it's it's interesting to me that
the audience
followed you with no casualties you know
what's so funny that's the first joke i
wrote about being bipolar and it worked
so well i tried it at comedy
off-broadway
uh in
kentucky
and it worked so well
that i remember i said to the crowd i
was like now i gotta do jokes about
this now cause i said i was like i
haven't done jokes about this yet and i
don't i don't know if i'm going to but
let me just try this
and
i tried it and it worked so well that i
was like
okay all right i guess we're we're doing
it now wow yeah so that's i love that
that's what came of it you tried it it
killed so hard and you're like you have
to do an hour on this well then well and
then i was like i got well cause i
thought a lot about it because like when
i told i talked to dustin about it
dustin nickerson very funny comedian and
uh he
he when i first told him another joke
that's in the special that is not a joke
is just something he literally said to
me which was so funny is i told him
about being bipolar and he was very nice
and sweet and said all the right things
your best friend's supposed to say and
then said you know your mental illness
was like your middle name i didn't know
what it was but i knew that you had one
which is an incredible line i said can i
use that yeah and then i did and
he was like initially he was like well
now you know you have your next hour you
can do your next hour on that and i was
like i don't want to do an hour
about
having bipolar 2 because that makes it
feel like
everything i felt
when i found out that i was
frustrated by or ashamed of was that i
felt
ashamed of it like it changed who i was
and what i don't know that people were
going to see me differently
and really like i said in the
special which is something my
psychiatrist said to me which was just
that this is just information about you
and now you know how to take care of
yourself
that's all and then you just adjust and
then everything's great it's not like
this bad thing it's just information
about who you who and how you optimize
how you work exactly that's it it's fine
so
i
once i wrote that joke i
was like okay i don't want it to be a
huge part of the hour but it is a
significant thing that happened to me
and something i do want to talk about
but if it's too much
it's gonna
i think
make it seem like
this traumatic thing so i wanted
i i like the arm floaties bit because
it's it's
communicating that it's just like hey
it's just something about you
like i know i just spent like six
minutes on it but that's not the entire
hour that's not all i'm gonna talk about
here it's just a part of me it's a piece
of me it's something i learned this year
and when i wrote that joke i was like
now i have to make sure that i'm writing
things around it that because if it was
just that joke it still sounds like a
bad thing
it sounds like you're being a
yeah so i'm like now i have to
make it clear that i don't i'm not
receiving it as a bad thing this is
funny it reminds me when a like a big
rapper someone puts out a diss track
against them and then they're like well
now i gotta do but you want that like
you you had a reason to write now like
you didn't want to be misunderstood yeah
i was afraid to write about it because i
just didn't want to say the wrong thing
and i didn't want to make people
feel bad
and i didn't i just didn't want to
mess up i guess i was like well if i'm
going to talk about it i want
people to
i don't want to make fun of it and be
like oh i'm this thing now look
how up i am like i didn't want it
to be that so i was i was nervous about
that and that was the only
like i think we tried to put like that
joke in a
sizzle reel or something like you know
it's just the worst tried to use it to
promote something and i was like we
can't just use that joke alone
without
more context because i don't want people
to see it and think
that i'm like
being bipolar like i suck for this
like that's not i hate being bipolar
it's amazing
yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that is sort of making a joke
out of it without
fully
yeah exploring it yeah i think that's
really interesting but you had a reason
to write and i think and and then this
there was urgency behind the hour it's
also it was happening now you're never
going to feel the way you feel about it
right at the beginning ever again so you
have to put it together yeah and you
just as you get older you go i don't
need to write it i don't need to do all
the jokes i come up with about
everything
so i was like maybe i shouldn't do any
jokes about it maybe that needs to be
something i keep for myself
and i thought about it for a long time
and ultimately decided i wanted to talk
about it
but i was like well you can't take that
back you can't then everybody knows like
i don't know and then i was like but
that's why you should talk about it
because the fact that you don't want
people to know
is sad and ridiculous and part of the
stigma and so that's why you should be
doing jokes about it so it was very
complicated there was a lot of feelings
i had about it and like that's where i'm
at with the stuff with my dad where like
i have jokes i've written about what
happened with my dad but i have a lot of
complicated feelings about it where i'm
like do i
is this something i want to put out
there is this something i want peop
other people to know is this
fair to
talk about the worst thing somebody else
did
even though it happened to me and
affected me
is it entirely mine to
you know
be public about and tell my son i mean
what led to the falling yeah the things
he said yeah yeah they just you know
there's a lot but it's just there's
you know
no money wasn't involved no i wish there
was money involved you wish it was just
i wish it was that simple yeah yeah no
it wasn't that it just like
you know i think as you get older
i think it's you can make a lot of
excuses for your parents
and it's hard sometimes to realize how
bad certain things were until you're
older and i used to have a joke about it
um about like you don't realize your
parents did certain things that were
really bad until you talked to other
people and they're like right and i
think everybody has that experience yep
it's pretty common but
even that makes you go like everybody's
parents did up and you have
to hit like a certain breaking point
where you go like oh no this really
isn't okay and yes but then at the same
time i have a lot of um
i have a lot of empathy
i guess and sympathy and honestly pity
uh for
where he's at and i don't want to
i don't want to be the sort of
artist who just like
burns everything to the ground anymore
or just goes like everything is material
for me
to play with and like this is my next
one man show like i i get nervous about
that and i i've tried to be
careful about it over the years when i
do talk about
parents or exes or whatever that i'm
always trying to make it sound like
it's also my fault well you did a great
job with that there's a part of your
special where you're kind of saying it
right into the lens where you're like
you turned him into your floaties and
that wasn't a safe relationship for him
yeah that was
as scathing as anything you said
against anyone else and it was clearly
against yourself or oh yeah that's the
yeah dustin told me that he's like
that's the most vulnerable vulnerable
part of the special is where you take
responsibility for what happened with
insert my ex-fiance's name here and i'm
like yeah like that's brandus yeah
it was brandis right
brandes brandeis brendas that's really
really interesting i i like what you're
talking about because i think there's a
certain point where it's not
whiny or naggy or or weak or bad but you
have to go like hey my is my
and what happened wasn't really okay and
that and that's okay yeah you know what
i mean like i have certain family
members i'll complain about my family
and i can still see the program they're
running where it's like yeah they did
the best they could or whatever it was
like uh we we didn't have it as bad as
the johnsons remember the johnsons they
were kleenox boxes for shows or whatever
it was or at least we had this or at
least we had that and that's all
beautiful and those are nice defense
things that kind of keep things
copacetic and running inside that's fine
i'm for that i still have some of those
programs and they benefit me but i also
through therapy found that it's okay at
some point to go like yeah no my parents
didn't uh hit me or whatever you want to
say but there was this and that hurt me
in this way and that's okay i don't
think anything is gained in having this
like
the great depression mentality where
it's like sure my parents said this this
and this but have you seen the value of
a dollar there's bigger fish to fry
right like go ahead and fry your fish
your fish are valid right right it seems
to be the lesson you're learning yeah
where you're like they fed me so i can't
be mad right about the psychological
torment like that kind of thing where
you're like no that's not doesn't rock
have that bit about like you're supposed
to like i ever put a roof over it yeah
and it's like that's what you're
supposed to do yeah i have a bed about
it too where my daughter didn't thank me
i cooked her lunch and she didn't say
thank you and i was like yeah you know i
yanked you into this yeah yeah i sort of
owe you yeah you don't owe me anything i
don't know you yanked you into it yeah i
thought it was so funny too i only did
it once it worked okay but yeah and i
also turned down my parents i was like
your father worked hard to send you to
college just like he should have
he yanked me into this yeah
you know this is spiritualizing it but i
was just
nothing
no thing is another way to look at
nothing meaning i was just totally fine
and then suddenly i'm feeding i'm like i
have man boobs and like peeing on my own
pants and stuff like
uh yeah you should make me lunch yeah
yeah
absolutely that's so funny i would love
to give you my hour and just be like can
you rewrite this
do you are you concerned about um
writing jokes uh as a parent like are
you gonna run your jokes about
about leela yeah
past her
you know it's interesting maybe if you
have any
i have some jokes about what is a joke i
had about her she's too young right now
but i have a joke about pulling down her
diaper and pushing her her butt against
the window of a val's car
right that's but then she started
pooping and it was at some smearing
she's a baby i agree so but it did occur
to me that i was like she might not like
like i
i'm trying to stay in touch with the
part of me that when my parents would
tell some story usually about my brother
like remember when you sang the meow
meow meow song and you really hated it
yeah so i don't want to do that but i'm
also like
i don't know we treat leela like she's a
a celebrity and i don't mean that in a
weird way i'd be sort of nervous
talking like i just want her to like me
so badly you know what i mean that's so
funny if she pays attention to us or
like
if she holds my hand i'm like
like there's no that's so funny
i guess there's this might be
self-serving but we don't we really
don't feel like we own her we just can't
so when she chooses us or like
snuggles with us watching tv we're just
like she's also pretty fierce yeah so
she doesn't always want to snuggle so
when she does you're like really really
into it she's like a cat she is like a
cat so if you ever do
have a joke
about her you probably will be like is
this cool with you
i think so yeah i do that with val yeah
one of my favorite memories is when we
were doing crashing i was just like
i don't know i've called val so many
nicknames
over the years but i was like is it okay
if i'm just if we're riffing and i say
boo or so let's say i was calling her
boo and i called the actress boo she's
like that's fine but then she was like
there was one nickname that she didn't
want me to use and it was really sweet
she was like let's say it was senator
lonely pants she was like just don't
call her senator lonely and i was like
you do care that's really nice yeah yeah
it's so yeah i'm i feel very strongly
about that in relationships now
yeah where when i was younger
i was kind of like this is what it is
you signed
a few years ago i started being like if
there's ever anything that you don't
like
it's gone it's out like
it's i had a joke about something my
grandma said that i ran past her before
quarter life
and she like
at first was fine with it and then
thought about it for a day and was like
you know what maybe not and i was like
gone done really yeah what was it
you just do i just do it i'm like oh
i'm sorry pete asked
no but it's like you know and it was
something i didn't think was that bad at
all but like it's up to everybody so
like yes
i think i'm trying to think i had a joke
about val having big boobs and somebody
sent me a screen grab when my special
aired
the number of people that googled pete
holm's wife boobs like oh yeah kind of
drove home just what an age we're living
in yeah first of all don't google it
nothing comes up
but like what do you think who do you
think i'm dating right and then
it but it made me realize just how
interconnected and how everything is
available and yeah so it isn't just me
saying she has big boobs it's
potentially
people looking at her in a specific way
or which is her business
in a peripheral way yeah so that made me
more sensitive too yeah it's just you
know and it's just figuring it out i
mean i
my special came out
during covet at the beginning of kovid
and
so
my life changed a lot during like
quarantine
and that was a weird time
to be like and also i was like dating
somebody who's also
a
public figure a comedian and
i think like
that was interesting to go through that
of like oh this is like a very public
not that like
you're not like
benefit or anything like no one gives a
but some people like no i remember
people ask
you know that was a part of our
quarantine
that apartment and your two heads yeah
it was
you're like we'll do a web series and
we'll do a podcast if i saw that i would
be taken back to the feeling of like two
weeks this is two weeks ah that's
hilarious that's so funny no and i'm
like i'm so grateful for like that
period of time and but like
it was and i think we did a really good
job
when we did break up like i
think we were super
respectful and like didn't talk about it
but like you just have people
dming you about it like i had somebody
on the street in new york come up to me
and be like are you doing oh my god i'm
listening to
you so it's this podcast like that's so
cool and like talk to me for a little
bit
and then was like is this too personal a
question can i ask if you go and i'm
like
sure you can ask i guess like it's just
a weird thing where you forgive yeah
yeah
but i was so you know i was really
i you know you put a lot out there and
then you forget it's the same with doing
jokes about like your sexual preferences
and then everybody's like so you like it
this way and you're like who told you
that oh it was me
so it's
it's the same thing where like now going
forward in relationships like
it's
i don't i don't anticipate being in that
situation again where i'm
dating another comedian where we're
having people
yell our names at each other at shows
and
i don't i don't anticipate that
happening again but like
it it does make you go into things going
like okay how much am i gonna share
of my
personal life
you know going forward based on the new
information i have like i don't really
post my family either
because
i just you know people are weird
i think about this with
i know it's such a cliche but i had
this revelation that ended in you're
your own worst enemy
which is a cliche unfortunately because
as i was having the revelation i was
like this the world needs to know this
but it's become just a trouble like or
maxim like you're your own worst enemy
but there's it's really true i worry
about my alexa or whatever
snooping on us but it's me who talks
about
whatever
jerking off or some weird thing that if
my alexa leaked it i'd be like hey but
it's you well what's the difference it's
just a story i tell myself that i'm like
but i leaked it similarly if the
government was putting something in the
air that was raising my cholesterol and
increasing my chance of dying i'd be in
the streets picketing but if it's me
eating french fries at 3am i'm like i'm
king ralph
1984 it's king ralph and i'm just loving
life but it's me that's murdering me
yeah and it's me that's rude like
spilling my privacy yes that's
yeah so it's just more
you just got to think three steps ahead
before you do the valboob joke well
that's what it is i it's not even kids
as much as i'm just realizing
like the joke i always reference is i
have a bit called i hate my girlfriend's
friends and i really like that joke but
like it's awkward having dinner with my
in-laws and i know they've probably seen
it yeah there's a whole part about how i
don't like in-laws i don't need to
double up on parents yeah i've never
been with my parents and been like i
need more of this yeah and it ends
with uh what are we going to fish i
your daughter which is a good line she's
a grey line but and you're like and i
and i don't feel that way but i do
i don't and i do yeah we're back to
paradox can it be both it's both i've
grown past that and it's still kind of
true
you hate me but you love me but i love
you and i hate you and all that sort of
stuff yeah i dated i i
had a moment with someone i was dating
where they were like they heard a joke i
did
about like wanting a guy who like gives
up on his dreams and just stays home and
takes care of my kids wow and
they were like i feel like that's really
what you want i'm like it's not but it
is but it's not like
that joke was about what i thought i was
in a place in my early 20s where i was
like what would actually work
practically
like for me it probably this and i
thought it was very funny but it didn't
mean that like everybody i dated while i
was telling that joke and after i was
just like can't wait till they give it
up like
i didn't feel that way at all i wanted
somebody who was really into their work
and their debt like of course i did but
in that moment it's also true
that if i
you know at 25 or whatever met somebody
who was like
had this dream but was like you know
what
let's have kids instead like i that also
would have been great like there was
it's both
i also think
it's a whole council up there it's a
whole board room and i think one of the
things that comedy does is it gives the
microphone to different aspects of your
personality that you usually repress
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
let's get the horny guy horny is always
my go-to because when you're horny
sex makes a lot of sense and when you're
not horny it doesn't make any sense yeah
but i think that's that's like a lot of
when you're hungry food makes a lot of
sense and when you're not hungry all of
the when you're desperate you know when
you're this when you're that so
when i watch for example bill burr who i
know is a compassionate and loving and
kind person and he goes on stage and
he's letting certain parts of his psyche
have the mic
that's actually i think it can be a
service it can be
interesting and difficult at times
because that's what it's like up here
interesting and difficult sometimes you
do have a voice that says like i just
want a guy that would give up on his
dreams and be with brent you know i mean
and i think there's a real loneliness in
thinking you're the only one we're back
to
when you am i the only one that's
hearing that yeah it's like
i remember i haven't thought about this
in a while but when i got stoned
one time and i went to you ever go to
bed but it's just it's just kicking in
like you you thought you were getting
like you ate an edible or something yes
have you ever done weed yeah i used to
use
edibles like every night okay it turned
on me oh
i know yeah that happens to a lot of
folks i know i would take an edible and
then i'd silly go to bed and it was too
strong and now i'm just in bed stoned
like you thought it would help you sleep
but you're just like riding the
hurricane and being really stoned yeah
but i was like oh my god stand up is
beautiful because it's looking at what's
what it's like to have a brain
and then reporting back to the tribe and
then they all go like oh it's not just
me it's not just me and that's again
like we're our own worst enemy that
seems so obvious but i think that's
actually really
special if you can go in
find weird thoughts present them proudly
and have other people who either don't
have the interest or the time or the
luxury to do that go ugh i'm less alone
i'm less afraid all that sort of stuff
yeah
let's pray
heavenly father
do you have any god you sow zero god
i just don't know yeah i don't have zero
god i just don't know yeah i have very
profound moments of like
oh man whatever it is i feel it i love
it it's good really finish your mushroom
story like that was that one yeah that's
how i felt i just felt like wow like it
was the most empathetic compassionate at
peace
i had ever felt and was just like it's
really all fine like
i had a lot i have a lot of feelings
about death and dying where i'm just
like well if it's gonna happen like what
are we even doing who cares like this is
pointless and then on mushrooms i'm like
because it's just it's not it's just not
yet just not now and when that happens
that'll be fine too and right now it's
fine like
but i don't feel that way naturally that
is a mushroom specific feeling
[Music]
so but so there's no but you wouldn't
say you're an atheist you're just sort
of like uh i don't know what you're
saying
agnostic
yeah oh that's agnostic
yeah if somebody like told me i'm very
open
to whatever like i think
nothing sounds
super crazy to me
unless it's
i know exactly what it is that sounds
crazy to me but if people are like i
think maybe it's just
we're all connected and maybe we come
back and something else maybe not like
that all right that's very attractive to
me
not so much close your eyes and found a
bindery on the other side of which it is
not look that will just make me i've
always had that like since i was little
i had a lot of that like well why is it
like why are we like don't look at your
hands too long like that kind of thing
that's the feeling i don't like where
there's like there's no
there's no
[Music]
resolution to that feeling you just
gotta watch tick tock and get your mind
off of it i know what you mean you know
it's either fun for you to go like how
am i that's not fun for me how am i
doing this yeah i'm like i barely
thought did you see that didn't even
think about it i'm not even thinking
about this well do you think about it or
do you just remember that it happened
like what just happened that's what i'm
saying i hate this i hate what we're
doing
i hate it so much i just want to have
hands and use them when i need to i
don't want to think too much about it
look
you don't i i want to say this as your
peer and as your equal but for what it's
worth i just think it's lovely i was
going to say you don't need my
validation but i'm giving it to you
i just think it's great it's all good
did your dad really say
be a werewolf like when you have bad
feelings run into the woods uh no but he
said that those were tags but he said um
he said those were tags those were tags
how comedy works is um
you say the true thing and then they get
increasingly more ridiculous and those
are the texts
there's an initial laugh and then you
build on it
no but he did say he was like when i
feel like this i just get as far get as
far away from people as you can you
really said that he really said that
yeah until you feel different he said a
lot of things he also said if i weren't
a christian i'd be in jail like there's
just a lot of that's a common one for
for
and it always troubles me i actually
rift on it scary whereas like when
they're like what's to stop me from
raping and murdering i'm like yeah
they're like the things i think about
though you're like wow okay
the only thing is that's keeping you
from that is a book it's an old book
that doesn't seem like enough when penn
jillette did this podcast he was like if
the only thing keeping you from those
activities is the bible you have bigger
problems yes like you have you have
something going on but it's it's crazy
how that's really what makes it a joke
or or interesting or worth mocking is
how openly people will say that it's
like if it weren't for
hell
i'd be killing people yep
what what yep
how detached we've come from
you know you're in that one and i'm in
this one but we're the same yeah you
know what i mean yeah scary but then
you're also like thank god for the bible
because i didn't know how many up
people we were cutting down on yeah with
this book i guess yeah
boy i hate to agree with that but there
is something sort of uh pragmatic about
just like look that's a weird way to
interpret it but if it's stopping you
from killing me that's why i'm alive
right now happily
i'll happily take it
uh well
i'm sober emo eater oh emotionally
emotional either dave the show dave
breakup's major recurring issue
therapy medication
panic night i just wrote down night for
a night here
we're done with this
um
that's going to burn thank you so much
for watching it that's so nice it was
very nice that was real katie right
there it's an hour i like that we have
the fan on you and both katie and i are
pretty glistening
it's the sleepy section i didn't
appreciate that that was no no question
nice view couple a couple simple
questions and we'll we'll end
one
uh
what's your deal no i'm just getting one
when are you gonna stop
what are you gonna give it up
um
what can you is there anything in your
life it could be a ghost who inspires
you
could be a ghost oh
yeah uh i like things that like
don't compute don't make sense
uh
it could be a ghost it could be a you
went to a psychic and they told you
something it could be
anything supernatural paranormal
uh
anything you can't explain in that realm
ufo
i don't think i can explain anything
that this is the space conversation
again yeah where it's like i can't
explain any of it i don't know why my
hand's doing this yeah that's right it's
all of it like are you talking about
like an instance that happened that
you're like that that's weird i mean
this is
what a coincidence is their meaning
well and i opened the door and it was
john f kennedy or whatever like like
this is where the people unload their
ghost stories this is where people
unload i was on a roof in brooklyn and i
saw a flying dorito oh i wish i had one
of those nothing like that no not even
no i used to have i used to have um
i used to have dreams about people
right before uh i
like started dating them seriously like
before i really knew them at all i would
have a dream about them and be like
that's weird this is a random person and
then i'd start dating them that happened
like
on like three and i great answer now i'm
you're bipolar like that was probably
what that was you're assigning meaning
to your brain was just grabbing at
people
in sort of floating around in your
subconscious from social media or
whatever but at the time it wasn't like
i've never seen that person before i see
and then i met them and was like you're
from my dream like it was people like
it was people i barely knew
that i would have a dream about and i'd
go that's where i'd dream about them and
then they would somehow
we would somehow meet or connect or
whatever and so that was weird but then
i got medicated and that stopped
happening so
and that's why you never met the love of
your life and that's agilio francisco
uh i like that one i thought i was just
gonna i almost interrupted to say i
thought that was a great answer i also
know you mean val was looking at
instagram last night before bed and i
went casting your dreams
casting your dreams what are you doing
yeah yeah i can't do it i have never
been like a manifest person like i don't
really think like i'll do it because i'm
a white lady obviously just in case but
i don't generally what do you feel about
manifesting
it's a big conversation it's a big
conversation down i tend to go like
i should get manifesting like if i'm
kind of like in an uncertain place in my
life yeah um
real quick to make it a quick answer
i've had a lot of times in my life
where i've met somebody who is exactly
what i was picturing or this thing
exactly what i had been like obsessing
about and dreaming about and thinking
about like working with jed like really
a lot of people have that feeling but
like i was really like aiming towards it
and i was really aiming towards working
with conan and both of those things
happened um in a really
uh interesting way so i can't discredit
it but i will tell you that i recently
so these past couple months have been
sort of slow i was thinking about what i
wanted to have happen so i made a little
vision board i'd never done a vision
board before but i was like wrong
punches does it and one of them was jon
hamm and a picture of what the show was
about this tv show i written i was like
jon hamm i even did some of the things i
would write it down sometimes i'm like
i'm so happy and grateful that jon hamm
loved my script and he has attached
just because i was like even if this
doesn't work yeah i'm i'm still happy i
need to enjoy the fantasy exactly yeah
and then john him texted me and he was
like he did love the script but he's
like i can't attach it this time it's
it's i can't do it so then it's a weird
feeling when my phone will occasionally
be like one week ago today and it's that
picture and i'm like
what do you make of that and i'm like
i don't
i don't know i don't i don't think it's
like a magic always work sort of thing
and i don't even think it's about
i think it's more about finding what i
was saying earlier the flow i'm open to
the flow being making a tv show john him
but that doesn't mean i'm going to force
that into reality because if you really
stop and think about how many other
lives that be affecting
by my will
it's uh it's i think it's infinite if
you look at the ripples that would if
jon hamm did that yeah for six months
and the crew and the writers and the
actors like i'd be affecting a huge
portion of humanity i don't know because
you you pointed out were we were pattern
recognizing machines for sure
but val and i when you're in the flow
let's just enjoy this whether or not
it's literally true
but it just feels like that like when
you're
being who you're meant to be
being with who you're meant to be so in
your case talking to kelsey meeting this
guy like
synchronicities just kind of show up
like they happen to us i mean like 10
out of 10 crazy synchronicities where
like
they happen so often val and i just
share them briefly we used to write them
down but now we're just like uh and
remember he said uh al madrigal and then
later al magikal called me and he's
called me twice in my life for whatever
yeah and things like that
like very often
we'll be looking for a phrase like
toboggan
and then like later that night we decide
to watch something different at night we
watch an old episode of whatever we've
never seen before and they say toboggan
like five times and we're just like
at this point we're just like i don't
know
the way you feel about god is the way i
feel about this stuff yeah i think what
what we need to do is
be humble
and open and like with my john ham thing
there's no downside to just being like
hey i'm game i'm saying yes to a lot of
things i'm putting out a lot of feelers
you're putting out feelers for this
person whether or not it happens like
you're doing your part you know what i
mean if this doesn't happen it's not
going to be because of a lack of vision
on your part because i will say
you do have to see it first i bet when
you were young you saw
the taylor tomlinson that you are today
you know in terms of your career
there was a part of you that could there
was a part of me yeah for sure they
could believe it yeah maybe even a small
part yeah and i didn't mean to put that
maybe you didn't feel that way i did but
no i just didn't not with stand up
specifically because i didn't know how
to do that i didn't know what it was so
so sheltered but i did feel that right
yeah it's like preaching yeah but with
more f-bombs exactly
not too many more um and the final
question i'm so thrilled that you did
thank you for coming in oh my god thank
you for having me um
can you think of a time in your life
where you laughed really really really
hard
uh oh my god yes i had one
it's so recent okay yes i do have one
i'm gonna try to i'm gonna try to read
it i don't know if i'll be able to read
it it's a text or something so i have
it's it's a tweet and i want to make
sure i
where it's on the oh my god i lost my
phone okay it's just
what is time um
okay i
also got off of twitter um so this is
back on twitter it just says bec so i
guess it's at back on twitter
every time a new stranger things season
drops people are like we all love blurpy
the beloved new character and then a
week later how could they just kill
blurpy like that open your eyes
i have sent that to so many people
and i still can't read it without
laughing just how could they just kill
blurpy like that open your eyes
that is
there's a certain
breath take away feeling to that joke i
love that isn't that nice it's really
fun this that's why i watch stranger
things to feel a part of something
and that tweet was so i laughed so hard
yes did they do that again sees four
have you not watched it because after
you have a baby uh oh you don't care
well val didn't well i don't care and
val didn't want to watch the scary oh
yeah they did they did that this season
again yeah yeah they they brought in
another blurpy always a blurt and
blurped them right out my only stranger
things bit was the scariest things in
stranger things is that it's the awkward
years
there are parts of it where you were
like
she's getting bullied like is she gonna
get her period like where's the demi
gorgon like
you are a little bit like cause they're
doing the 80s thing also but you're like
i don't really care like it could have
been shorter that's my review of this
season i didn't hear anybody talking
about it oh i feel like everybody oh
where are they yeah this is that val and
i are just in the house with a baby you
really are right and nobody was talking
about it
you know why because i have a bit where
i put in whatever show i think
everyone's talking about and he's like i
can't do stranger things nobody's eating
stranger things is massive you can
absolutely what were you using instead
of strangers well i would do stranger
things first three seasons i've been
doing the joke for a while then i
changed it to ted lasso and that was
real hot and then i thought about
putting it back to stranger things and
now i might stranger things is is it
it's it yeah it was it good it was okay
too long
now we're just talking everyone i talked
to is either like it was the greatest
season ever yeah
or they're like me where they just feels
pretty long
the fun every episode was an hour and a
half long really and there were nine and
the last one was two and a half
i'm gonna go ahead and say this uh i
think it's because i'm 43 and because i
have a baby but like i can't i can't
care
yeah i've started doing what i have that
i have a joke about how my mom called
celine dion salon dijon it takes me so
long to remember the names of like
anything yeah like i struggled to find
harrison ford the other day and i was
like
you know what it is everybody just wrote
gun guy star wars
hans
question mark
uh
why daughter
you know co-regulates it's something
we've sort of talked about without
talking about it it's like in
relationships another person can help
you
regulate your life like they're there
with you to help you with your life and
with leela
i have another brain now when she says
something like i'm really locked on and
listening and she's saying a lot of kind
of nonsense a lot of the time just
saying like booty bomb and stuff she
loves saying booty bomb but every time
she says it i'm like what oh a booty
bomb okay booty bomb so it's like i have
another stream i have two streams of
consciousness in my brain so i'm
exhausted do you know does that make
sense like i have another brain that i
have to listen to
as intently as i do to my own brain
right that's that's that's why all
parents are so tired that makes sense
and also you don't care about stranger
things like i i think about the me that
used to play like a video game and was
like where do you get the key to the
dungeon and i was like i'm trying to
find my actual keys like i can't find
the key to the dungeon that's so funny
i'm just checking the time okay where'd
you go um t tom whoa we went we went a
long time
2 35
look at us
we did it we did it i'm so glad we did
did you enjoy it i did yeah did you
enjoy it i did i really enjoyed it i
really enjoyed it i was nervous and we
already covered that yeah i was nervous
too
have you ever almost died
you sneak it in i feel like we talked
did we talk about this in the first
place
i feel like i almost got murdered on
alaska once what but yeah it's not like
i don't wanna you know i wasn't like in
the car but yeah i got left at a college
after i did a gig all the kids left and
they're like you're fine right i was
like yeah i called a taxi and the taxi
took like 45 minutes to come and so i
was just sitting there and i was like i
can go back in the building if i have to
but then the building was locked so it
was just there and there's this guy in a
pickup truck who started circling the
building i was standing by oh and after
a few uh times he went around he like
got out of his car and was like
coming at me and then what do you mean
like just how fast i mean a very uh you
know a pretty aggressive walk i hate
this story uh yeah and i think i was
like you know when you just all the play
it's just you know you're like well this
is it like there's literally no one here
i can't run anywhere like it's happening
right now and then as he was coming
toward me the a taxi
finally the taxi showed up my phone also
wasn't working for some reason wherever
we were yeah because we're in a horror
movie because we're in a horror movie in
alaska welcome to the gig taylor yeah
you'll notice your phone doesn't work i
know and so then the taxi was coming up
and with the taxi pulled out just in the
neck yeah and as the taxi pulled up he
when he
i saw the taxi and he turned and saw it
and then as soon as he saw it he turned
around and ran back to his car and drove
away
so if he was like a nice person he would
have been like oh good i was just making
sure like that would have been the but
he wasn't that
so everyone hates this story i know it's
a rough one everyone hates yeah and then
i like went back to my hotel room and
called my ex-boyfriend like thank you so
much for always making sure you knew
where i was
oh my god
yeah it was a rough this is a rough one
but that happened you know that
happened when you're like young and 21
and doing
like weird colleges and like nothing
towns like i had people try to break
into my hotel rooms at like 2 a.m and
oh yeah where you'd like call the front
desk and be like why why was someone
trying to get into my room was that a
mistake and they were like we don't know
and you're like oh okay glad i latched
it
yeah you mean the door opened oh yeah it
was like punk yeah
and was that a gunk oh multiple times
yeah multiple times chigunk yeah which
is why now i'd like stay in safer hotels
and stuff but at the time you're just
staying in the cheapest option
in again nowhere vil
yeah in between gigs like in the winter
and you're 21 i'm like very young i'm by
myself
you know
yeah
only only this face i know i don't know
what it is because
as a parent now too i'm just like i'm
dead yep can't yeah dead it's very scary
i'm so glad you're okay i'm glad we went
out on a high note
all right when's the last time you
farted accidentally in front of somebody
yeah i'm just gonna eat it in a while
new relationship so i've been taking a
lot of offensive pepto
you know what i mean you know when you
take it you're like i'm fine but i'm
gonna make sure i'm fine
yeah why aren't girls all over gas x
they i i am i think they are are they i
don't know that explains it yeah really
i thought it was just something with the
ovaries absorbed all the words no no
we're
we're taking care of that parent that's
pre-emptive
i take my birth control and my pepto at
the same time
do it on this day should i okay it's so
funny it's also just like revelatory to
me that i'm like who
knew yeah
i have a joke about when i was working
on the last show i was working on the
best part of it was at the end of the
day you'd go in your car and fart and i
tell it to watch people not laugh
because it's a fart joke and i'm like
guys look we just have to talk about
this like i know it's not like cutting
edge but it's the truest thing i can say
yeah and it's one of the best feelings
in the world yeah
it's really nice
it's relief it's pure relief it's pure
relief yeah it's solo you time yeah
what's the last thing you did for
yourself
farted alone in my car it's like a
little trip to orlando it is
yeah when i fart that's what it sounds
like orlando it's just
that song from book of mormon
well
thank you
watch
look at you on netflix and we didn't
talk about it but you have to do a show
at some point i'd love to do a show yeah
yeah all right
i'll write it oh you mean a tv show i
thought you meant your show at least you
could do my logo chair yeah that's how
low my self-esteem is i was like oh you
want me to do a show where's the tea
time we're trying to get we're trying to
get a movie made right now so we'll see
how that goes if anything happens but
nothing ever does so
this is i mean yeah i mean it will
happen
manifest
and jon hamm is attached wait no he's
gonna do it now he's gonna do it i had
him in my in my swirl but it was for you
it was for me
thank you taylor would you say keep it
crispy keep it crispy there it is for
the second time that was awesome thank
you
[Music]